Das ist jetzt untertitelt etwas faul!
Voll lustig, ist aber geil!
Na dann, bis zum nächsten mal, ciao.
Was soll am 1.1. um 9 Uhr schon groß gehen?
Oh, recommended channels, Amorant, Poolstreams, ne was wird recommended?
Alter, was wird da teilweise für Channels empfohlen werden?
Habe ich noch nie reingeguckt, noch habe ich das großartig vor, aber gut.
Wenn Twitch das meint, dass ich das gucken soll, dann gucke ich es trotzdem nicht, aber.
Tja, ich weiß nicht, wie lange ich jetzt on bin, ich bin übelst müde, heute Nacht
kannst du ja nicht wirklich pennen.
Ich hoffe heute passt der Sound wieder halbwegs, ich habe jetzt die ganzen OBS Settings kopiert
und sowohl Lautstärke als auch Bilder und solche, das sollte eigentlich alles passen,
aber man weiß ja nie was Windows, also bei Settings und Windows und Sachen, also generell
muss ich sagen, also Windows 11, ganz im Ernst, ich verwende das jetzt seit 2 Wochen ungefähr
und es hat gewisse Vorteile, die Vorteile sind aber hauptsächlich, weil Microsoft sagt,
diese Sachen gibt es halt einfach nicht mehr für Windows 10, also nicht notwendigerweise
und nicht weil sie es besser gemacht haben, sondern einfach weil sie es bei den alten
Apps explizit auslassen, klingt anders, ich muss mir das mal kurz anhören, es sollte
mehr oder weniger gleich, also gut, es kann sein, dass weil ich jetzt, mal kurz meinen
eigenen Stream anhören, kurz meinen eigenen Stream aufmachen und gucken, wie sich das
anhört.
Oh Gott, jetzt muss ich mir alle die Werbung von meinem eigenen Kram angucken, ja wunderbar,
der Original Alipreis, so lass mal kurz gucken, der Original Alipreis, naja ne, passt eigentlich,
ist eigentlich okay, ja wahrscheinlich hört sich einfach an, weil es heute erst der erste
ist.
Ähm, was wollte ich jetzt gerade sagen, ja also Windows 11 Leute, ohne Scheiß, es hat
ja gewisse Vorteile, einfach weil Windows 10 manche Sachen nicht bekommt, wie zum Beispiel,
ich weiß gar nicht, wie man sich das jetzt anzeigen lässt, wie lässt man sich hier alle,
Logical Processors, ja, also wie zum Beispiel, dass man ordentlich die ganzen Efficiency
Cores in dem 13.900k verwenden kann, also ich meine, der sagt ja nur, es sind 31 CPUs,
das stimmt ja gar nicht, es sind nicht 31 CPUs, es sind 8 Kerne und nochmal, keine Ahnung,
12 oder, nochmal 8, nochmal 8, 8 normale Kerne, 8 Efficiency, ne, 16 Efficiency Cores und
8, ach was weiß ich aus dem Kopf, ich hab keine Ahnung, was in meiner CPU drin ist,
genau, zumindest der Task Scheduler, also dass die Efficiency Cores und das ganze Zeug ordentlich
verwendet werden, das gibt es nur unter Windows 11, das gibt es nicht unter Windows 10, das
ist auch so der eine Punkt, warum ich Windows 11 jetzt genommen hab, anstatt Windows 10.
So, aber Windows 11 hat so viele andere Dinge, die mir wirklich auf den Keks gehen und ich
hab den Eindruck, dass Windows 11 so ein Versuch von Microsoft ist, wie sehr man die Leute
gängeln kann und wie viel die noch mitmachen, so für Windows 12 dann oder sowas, anders
kann ich es mir nicht erklären, es sind so viele Sachen, es fängt ja schon an, dass
es jetzt richtig trickreich ist, das Ding überhaupt zu installieren, ohne lokalen Account,
ich will mich nicht mit einem Microsoft Account einloggen müssen, dass ich mein lokales
Windows, warum, das will ich nicht, die sollen mir nicht auf den Sack gehen, du kannst viele
Software auch gar nicht gescheit umziehen, ist mir aufgefallen, ich hab zum Beispiel
die Profile kopiert für Chrome, Chromium, Firefox, OBS, OBS und Firefox waren zu erwarten
überhaupt keine Probleme, Profile kopiert, geht, 1 zu 1, gar kein Problem, Chrome kopiert,
geht nur zur Hälfte, Chromium auch, geht nur zur Hälfte, Extensions kommen nicht mit,
Extensionsettings kommen nicht mit, manche normalen Settings kommen nicht mit, Sessions
gehen verloren, du musst dich überall neu einloggen, Firefox gar kein Problem, Profil
rübergeschoben geht, Chrome kannst du wieder vergessen, warum, naja ganz klar, weil die
Typen wollen, dass man hier ihren komischen Scheiß Google Sync Crap verwendet, es ist
sehr viel nerviges Zeug an vielen Stellen und dann geht's, das geht ja noch weiter,
dass du jetzt unter Windows 11 immer so hier machen musst, guck, seht ihr das, ich kann
nicht einfach, guck mal, ich hab so viel Platz hier unten, seht ihr das, so viel Platz und
ich muss jetzt so machen, damit ich mein richtiges Chrome Fenster finde und manchmal geht das
gar nicht, manchmal geht die Startleiste nicht in den Vordergrund, es ist hinter irgendeinem
Fenster, es ist unglaublich schlecht gemacht, gibt es kein Plugin für die Taskleiste, das
Ding unterstützt doch keine Plugins, was es gibt, es gibt so ein Replacement, was die
Windows 11-Taskleiste durch die Windows 10-Taskleiste replaced, aber das ist doch auch alles nur
temporäres rumgefreckelt.
Ich mein, ihr dürft nicht vergessen, es ging bis vor ganz, bis vor kurzer Zeit, ach, es
geht immer noch nicht, ok, ok, ok, also man konnte bis vor noch nicht, warte, ich kram
hier mal kurz zu, man konnte vor noch nicht allzu langer Zeit keine Sachen von der Taskleiste
und auf die Task, na gut, das geht nicht, guck, also man kann keine Sachen mehr von
und in die Taskleiste gescheit ziehen, ok, das funktioniert, also es ist sehr weirdchampig
gemacht alles, aber immerhin, wisst ihr was, dass es ein mega geiles neues Feature gibt,
richtig, richtig, richtig massive neues Feature, ihr habt es eben im Stream schon gesehen,
guck mal, man kann den Taskmanager jetzt über die Taskleiste wieder aufmachen, krass, oder?
Richtig krasses, oh, ich hab das Meme-Board nicht rüber kopiert, Leute, ich hab vergessen
das Meme-Board rüber zu kopieren, oder was geht mir denn mit der Musik jetzt ab, übertreib
ab halt, das gab es nicht, korrekt, du konntest bis zur letzten Windows-Version nicht rechts
klicken und sagen Taskmanager, das ist erst seit 2 Wochen oder so möglich wieder, kecke,
ist wirklich so, ich hab mir das nicht ausgedacht, ich hab vergessen das Meme-Board rüber zu
kopieren, ja gut, das bekomme ich jetzt nicht hin, gescheit, muss ich ein USB-Stick holen
oder so, ich hab in den letzten Tagen viele deiner alten Videos über Ausbildung und Beruf
geguckt, ja ich hab ja auch neuere, ich hab ja nicht nur die ganz alten Dinger, was ich
mich gefragt habe ist, ob du manchmal bereust nicht Informatikstudien, nö, gar nicht, warum
sollte ich das bereuen, nö, also denkst du aus irgendeinem speziellen Grund, dass das
der Fall sein könnte, du kannst mich ja mal konkret fragen, aber mir fällt jetzt nichts
ein, dass ich das bereut hätte oder bereuen würde, ganz davon abgesehen, ich bin viel
zu faul um noch was zu studieren, also ich bin zu faul um jetzt was zu studieren, das
auf jeden Fall und ich wäre auch deutlich zu faul gewesen, damals was zu studieren,
ja und mir ist aufgefallen, Windows bringt jetzt das neue Terminal mit, aber nicht Winget,
ah wie, doch, wait a minute, ach doch, ok, ok dann hab ich nichts gesagt, willi mir eigentlich
hat geguckt und da gab es kein Winget, ja, also Windows 11 ist echt so ein Ding, neuer
PC, ja, nee aber ohne scheiß, Windows 11 ist echt so ein Ding, das hätte die Welt nicht
gebraucht, das einzige, und Microsoft selbst sieht das ja ähnlich, guckt euch mal diesen
ganzen Schrott an, alter, was ist das hier, Whatsapp, Unpin, Spotify, Unpin, Disney+,
Unpin, Xbox, Unpin, Clipchamp, ok das hat einen guten Namen, aber trotzdem, Unpin, Prime Video,
Unpin, TikTok, Unpin, Instagram, Unpin, Messenger, Unpin, ok der Calculator läuft da, bleib
mal lahm und klox, brauch ich nicht, Tipps, Unpin, Office, Unpin, Microsoft Store, doppelt
Unpin, Mail, Unpin, Edge, Unpin, nice, sehr gut, toll, dass das alles voll ist, Solitaire
Casual, Unpin, Fotos, Unpin, Kalender, ja vielleicht irgendwann mal, keine Ahnung, oh man, es ist
auch so viel Schrott am Start, guckt euch das an, News, Unpin, nee, keine Ahnung, ja,
bleibt hier erspart, ganze Schrott der da vorinstalliert ist, aber trotzdem, Microsoft selbst weiß
ja im Endeffekt auch, dass es irgendwie außer ein bisschen Optik, und selbst das kann man
diskutieren, nicht wirklich was zu bieten hat, weil erinnert ihr euch noch an diese
Windows 11 Präsentation, im Prinzip haben die zwei Sachen gemacht, die haben permanent
erzählt wie beautiful das neue Windows ist, haben irgendwelche Widgets gezeigt, wo ich
mich frage, wer verwendet irgendwelche komischen Widgets, dieser Widget Crap war unter Windows
8 schon Müll, niemand will irgendwelche komischen Widgets, ich weiß gar nicht wie ich die überhaupt
aufmache hier irgendwie, ach übrigens noch was, was abgeschafft wurde, passt mal auf,
ich mache ja immer gerne Vmware auf, auf dem zweiten Bildschirm, ich glaube ich habe meine
VMs auch nicht umgezogen, nee, so und dann switche ich rüber, guckt mal, es gibt keine
Desktop Switch Animation mehr, die hat sich Microsoft geschenkt, früher gab es auch eine
Desktop Switch Animation, die tatsächlich ganz praktisch war, weil, wundert mich, dass
da bei Microsoft keiner dran gedacht hat, jetzt passt mal auf, tja, auf welchem, wenn
ihr mal die Icons hier unten nicht sehen würdet, auf welchem Desktop bin ich Leute, switche
ich den Desktop, tja, man sieht es nicht mehr, weil es keine, auch noch so kleine Desktop
Switch Animation gibt, Desktop Switch Animation wurde einfach entfernt, guck ich switche Desktops
und du siehst es überhaupt nicht, dass ich Desktop switche und gerade wenn du vielleicht
jetzt nicht unten auf die Icons guckst oder andere Sachen gestartet hast, hast du halt
gelitten, siehst du nicht, dass du Desktop switchst, es ist teilweise total undurchdacht,
ja also Microsoft hat ja auch die ganze Zeit nur erzählt, in ihrer Windows Presentation,
dass es so beautiful ist und dass es so emotional ist, wo ich mir gedacht habe, also wenn Windows
bei mir emotional ist, dann eigentlich nur, weil mich irgendwas abfuckt und nicht, weil
ich irgendwie mit Windows jetzt so die geilen Erinnerungen verbinde, eher damit, was ich
damals gemacht habe, ja, nicht mit Windows selbst, selbst an Windows 98, ich denke an
die Zeit natürlich gerne zurück, wo ich damals so richtig angefangen habe mit Games
und Half-Life rausgekommen ist und sowas, aber so, dass ich sagen würde, alter Windows
98 war das geilste ever im Leben nicht, keine Ahnung, die haben wie gesagt, diese zwei Sachen
hat Microsoft erzählt, die haben die ganze Zeit erzählt, es ist super beautiful und
sie haben es auch voll emotional gemacht und wo ich mir echt, wo ich mir echt oft an den
Kopf gegriffen habe ist, wo die eine in der Präsentation erzählt hat, sie erinnert sich
so gern an altes Windows zurück, als sie mit ihrem Vater noch vor dem PC gesessen hat
und so, das war so fail anstelle, ich meine gut, sie konnten ja auch nichts zeigen, was
hätten sie zeigen sollen, es gibt jetzt eine Taskleiste, wo du nicht mal den Taskmanager
aufmachen kannst oder, oder das, ach ne Moment nicht, Notepad hat Widgets, der Explorer,
ne nicht Widgets, der Explorer hat jetzt Tabs und komische neue Icons und sowas, aber unter
der Haube ist es halt immer noch der alte Kackexplorer, wobei der geht und was sie auch
noch haben ist, jetzt halt hinter 85 Menüs versteckt, stellt euch mal vor Leute, ich
möchte das Icon hier von ändern, tja, das gibt es gar nicht mehr oder was, ich meine
guckt mal, wisst ihr was das für, wie bescheuert das ist, also man kann doch nicht mal gescheite
Icons jetzt ändern anscheinend, also das ist wirklich echt richtig hängen geblieben.
Tabs ist, tatsächlich, das war wohl auch das einzige sinnvolle, ich meine man muss
sagen hier, guck mal, beispielsweise die neue Setting App, die ist schon besser gemacht
als die alte Settings App, aber ey, das war auch wirklich keine Kunst, aber nicht zu vergessen
Leute, wer gedacht hat, das Control Panel ist jetzt weg, nein, nein, nein, manche Sachen
wie gescheite Energie, ja also wenn ihr zum Beispiel eure, eure Idle Time für Festplatte
und sowas gescheit einstellen wollt und, und Shutdown und sowas ausschalten wollt gescheit,
dann müsst ihr weiterhin ins Control Panel in irgendein Windows 2000 Dialog, wo, wo schaltet
man diesen komischen, wo kann man das nochmal ausschalten mit Hibernate beim Shutdown, ich
glaube das habe ich ausgeschaltet, aber ich wollte jetzt mal nachgucken, ich weiß nicht
mehr wo es ist, Slideshow, naja alles klar, ich bin mir da auch nicht sicher, ich meine
bei vielen Sachen kannst du dich drüber streiten, wie es jetzt besser ist, aber ich kann mir
nicht vorstellen, dass irgendjemand gesagt hat, ja es ist besser, dass man jetzt alles
in Icons gruppiert hat in der Taskleiste, ich weiß nicht, ich kann mir nicht vorstellen,
dass das irgendjemand gesagt hat, ja RecEdit gibt es auch noch, ja, hast du beim Arctic
Coole eine Lüfterkurve eingestellt, kann man die Lüfter einstellen und die Pumpe immer
auf 100% lassen, also nachdem du nur einen Anschluss hast für dieses gesamte Ding, vermute
ich, dass das nicht geht, also du hast ja nur einen so PWM 4 Pin Connector, glaube ich
zumindest, ich habe es ja im Stream zusammengebaut, also das geht nicht, also ja ich habe eine
Lüfterkurve eingestellt, aber die Default Lüfter, ich kann euch das auch zeigen hier
irgendwo, und das hier, naja ich mache es hier lieber nicht auf, wer weiß, ob es dann
irgendwelche Settings kaputt macht, keine Ahnung, Leute ist das Display jetzt schwarz
bei euch, ne jetzt geht es wieder, ja, also ja ich habe die Standard Silent Lüfterkurve
eingestellt, aber nichts Spezielles sonst, ja, Netzwerk Settings sind auch äußerst
weird, was ich tatsächlich ganz gut finde, übrigens was auch witzig ist, das hier wird
kopiert angezeigt, aber es sind zwei unterschiedliche Buttons, was ich tatsächlich ganz gut finde
ist der neue Mixer, das ist im Prinzip das gleiche, aber ich finde es tatsächlich so
von oben nach unten angeordnet besser, du hast einfach mehr Platz hier für die Sachen,
das ist schon ok, die Mikrofonlautstärke, das geht nicht etwa da drüber, wenn du hier
aufs Mikrofon drückst, also ich meine, wer möchte auch schon die Lautstärke einstellen
wenn er aufs Mikrofon drückt, ne, logischerweise möchte ich Privacy und Security für mein
Mikrofon einstellen, wenn ich aufs Mikrofon klicke, ist ja logisch, und nein ich muss
dann, oh ich habe vergessen wo es geht, tja Leute, wie stellt man die Lautstärke vom
Mikrofon ein, da fängt es schon an, ich habe es gestern gefunden irgendwo, Sound Settings
vielleicht, Input, ah ja, ne ne ne, also Leute, wer denkt, dass er aufs Mikrofon klicken kann,
um die Mikrofonlautstärke einzustellen, nicht bei Microsoft, so geht das nicht, du
musst dir eine super ruckelige Anzeige anschauen, du musst auf den Lautsprecher klicken, rechts
und dann auf Sound Settings und dann runter zu Inputs, alles klar, logisch, obviously.
Ja, muss man nicht verstehen, naja, gibt so ein paar Sachen, wo ich mir denke, was, warum,
warum ist das da, ja ich muss echt mein Meme Board umziehen, aber kann ich jetzt nicht
gescheit machen, weil doch, kann ich, kann ich machen, wartet mal, New Ordner, wartet
mal, kacke, kacke weh, wie shared man jetzt hier was, Properties, Sharing, Share, Stream,
keine Ahnung ob ich das so richtig mache, Share, ok jetzt muss ich irgendwas eintippen,
kacke weh, Share, ok und jetzt kann ich da was drauf kopieren, Moment, das probieren
wir jetzt aus, ich weiß ja zum Glück die IP von der Kiste aus dem Kopf, Users, Stream,
äh, ich seh den Ordner nicht, ich seh den Ordner nicht, obwohl ich den grad geshared
hab, ist auch geil, lol, aber ich kann wahrscheinlich über die User Freigabe, so ich schieb mal
kurz, ich schieb mal kurz mein Meme Board rüber, dazu muss ich, ah dazu muss ich auf
den anderen Account, das brauche ich aber hier Leute, das müssen wir jetzt kurz machen,
ich log mich mal kurz um, schauen wir mal, jetzt bin ich mal gespannt, bin mal gespannt
ob ich das hinkriege hier rüber, das rüber zu kopieren, Stream einloggen, Stream Account
auf der einen Seite einloggen, geshared ein Folder aufmachen, hiaq Windows-Teuch jetzt
hier angesagt, Stream, Desktop, kacke weh, so Meme Board, wo liegt das, hier, Meme Tool,
da ist es doch, copy, ok es kopiert Leute, es kopiert, es kopiert mega langsam, aber
es kopiert, es braucht ne Minute das zu kopieren, das kopiert jetzt, wo ist mein, ah alter,
wo ist mein Desktop hier, da, shared, was nicht alles gibt, Notepad jetzt schon Tabs,
ne wäre mir neu das Notepad Tabs, Quatsch, alter, Notepad Tabs, du kannst jetzt, du kannst
jetzt Themes wechseln und sowas, ich meine immerhin ist nicht mehr dieser Schrott hier
am Start, sondern was ordentliches, nämlich das neue Windows Terminal, seht ihr, also
selbst wenn man CMD macht, ich weiß auch nicht was VC, VCTL, Containers mit vor allem
mal Workstation, alles klar, alles klar, so das Meme Tool ist kopiert, schauen wir mal
ob das jetzt funktioniert, kopieren wir das mal auf dem Desktop, weil das brauche ich
jetzt hier, achja was mir aufgefallen ist, wenn man Ordner kopiert hat, muss man prinzipiell
immer Read Only raus machen, hat jemand nen Plan warum, I don't know, keine Ahnung, Microsoft,
Microsoft Logik, geht eigentlich der Chat, Leute, geht die Chatvorschau, es schreibt
halt keiner was, irgendwie, schreibt mal einer Test oder so, gucken ob die Chatvorschau funktioniert
im Stream, sollte eigentlich, geht nicht, natürlich geht doch, Fake News, ok hier,
Meme Tool, ich hoffe dass das bin, oh Alter das ist ja ein uralt, uralt Programm, wie
hab ich denn das jetzt gestartet, Web Application, hier, ah, warum, warum, warum geht das nicht,
warum, ohje, well you can not be null, ahja, obviously, Data Protection Keys, was, was
will Windows von mir, was will, hä, was will, alter, ich will einfach was starten man, scheint
komplizierter zu sein als angenommen, ok ich muss mal angucken wie ich das hier starte,
ok ok ok, hier muss ich hin, hier muss ich hin, alles klar, ich weiß wie es geht, also
Debug, das ist uralt das Ding, ist wirklich uralt, ja, Web Application 11, so und jetzt
Properties, Start in da, und jetzt sollte es gehen, zack, yes, yes, Access, jawoll, schauen
wir mal, gleich, gleich, jetzt gucken wir mal, gucken wir mal ob meine Software funktioniert
unter Windows 11, jetzt hat er eh den besten, hat er eh den besten Namen, Web, Web Application,
Web Application 11, weiß eh jeder Bescheid, ne, welcher Port ist es, 5002, hey Leute,
es funktioniert, stellt euch das mal vor, einfach so, Skipzeit geht ja net, einfach
so man, ja Wahnsinn, so jetzt wollen wir den ganzen Kram noch verschieben, gehen die anderen
Sounds noch, Moment, wo, wo ist der kekwe Sound, da, ok funktioniert alles, exzellent,
haben es geschafft, ja das mag sein, aber in der aktuellen Form will das keiner verwenden,
davon abzielt, es ist ein wahrscheinlich ein.NET Framework 4.6 Projekt noch oder so, ja,
ok, immerhin, jetzt fühle ich mich nicht mal so nackig, jetzt habe ich wieder ein paar
Bildchen die ich einblenden kann, zum Beispiel, zum Beispiel kann ich euch auch jetzt gebaten,
bisschen Panik auslösen in manche, was ist hier los, warum schreibt der Chef am 01.01.
ist irgendwas kaputt, Produktivsystemausfall, Moment, wie ist eigentlich die Lautstärke
von den Sachen jetzt, das muss ich mal kurz kontrollieren, bisschen laut, wie macht man
das jetzt in diesem Volume Mixer, Main Window, alles klar, da weiß man Bescheid, ok, alles
klar, jetzt die Lautstärke, jetzt die Lautstärke, ok, ja Leute, ich weiß nicht, was wollen
wir jetzt machen, wir machen uns ein paar Sachen auf YouTube angucken, lasst mal schauen, was
habe ich hier noch auf, was haben wir hier noch, TikTok, oh ne, ne, please, please, kein
Plus, ach ja, was sagt er dann hier, what am I self-hosting in my home lab, wir haben
doch letzte Woche von diesem Typ geguckt, wo er uns sein neues Rack gezeigt hat, wo ich
schon immer gesagt habe, was macht er damit eigentlich und heute kriegen wir es anscheinend
erzählt, wir werden uns das nicht 38 Minuten angucken, ich werde einfach drüber skippen,
aber ich wette mit euch, es ist immer noch das gleiche wie vor 2 Jahren, dass er seine
wahnsinns Infrastruktur daheim hat, nur um die Infrastruktur zu betreiben, nicht um wirklich
was sinnvolles zu betreiben, woran er im Endeffekt auch was mit anfangen kann, das, das, das,
das muss ich mir jetzt mal anschauen, wir skippen da mal, guckt mal Leute, ich kann
noch nicht mal, es ist so ätzend, ich kann noch nicht mal hier irgendwie schnell jetzt
das finden, um die Musik auszumachen, es ist richtig dumm, es ist einfach richtig dumm.
Okay, laut genug, ja, weil es unsinnig ist, Dashboard, okay, es geht los mit einem Sinn,
Sinnlos Dashboard, der hat ja fast, eben hat er noch wirklich fast geguckt, wie dieser,
wie heißt der Meme-Opa nochmal, äh, Pain, show no, ach, fuck, bin ich jetzt blöd, Pain,
ihr wisst, was ich meine, Meme-Pain, ja, ja, genau, ihn meine ich, ja, hide the Pain, das
habe ich gemeint, genau, das habe ich gemeint, hide the Pain, äh, das Ding, das Ding habe
ich auch mal aus Schock-Zwecken aufgesetzt, ist ganz nützlich, aber ganz im Ernst, der
Sinn von Dashboards erschließt sich mir immer noch nicht, weil, seriously, man kann auch
einfach Browser, also man kann auch einfach Browser-Tabs verwenden und, nicht Browser-Tabs,
sondern Browser-Bookmarks verwenden und fertig, easy, geht genau so, aber, ja gut, wenn man
vielleicht dann vom Tablet drauf zugreift und irgendwie das versteht, aber es ist wahrscheinlich
noch das sinnvollste in seinem Setup, was ist, was ist Schink, oder, was ist Schink,
oder, nee, Schlink, was ist Schlink, Schlink, ein eigener Urlschortner, okay, das hat natürlich
die Welt gebraucht, okay, wir sehen ja schon hier im Prinzip, was er betreibt und das ist
nicht wirklich, nicht wirklich viel, was wirklich dafür da ist, um was zu machen, ja, Rancher
ist Infrastruktur, Tunas ist Infrastruktur, okay, es ist nass, das lasse ich auch mal
durchgehen, ja, aber, Infrastruktur, äh, was war Longhorn nochmal, das war der Codename
für Windows Vista, glaube, oder Windows XP, aber es ist irgendwas, irgendwas anderes,
Cloud Native Distributed Storage, genau, auch Infrastruktur, auch Infrastruktur, äh, ja,
auch Infrastruktur, auch Infrastruktur, Infrastruktur, Infrastruktur, Infrastruktur, Monitoring,
das ist Infrastruktur, drei, dreimal Piehole, einer tut's nicht, ähm, Homebridge, okay,
okay, okay, Infrastruktur, Infrastruktur, Infrastruktur, soll ich, also im Prinzip ist
das 90%, 90% seiner, äh, 95% seiner Sachen sind dazu da, um sich selbst zu verwalten,
also das ist auch irgendwie komisch.
Wir skippen, wir skippen, wir skippen ein bisschen, genau, genau, so ist es, I host
services, to host services und to host services, Proxmox, hat er nicht letztes Mal auch was
über VMware erzählt, wait, wait a minute, hat er nicht, hat er nicht, ähm, irgendwie
auch ein paar Kubernetes Cluster und Gedöns, die hat er quasi als VM auf Proxmox, oder
wie, oder, ach, keine Ahnung, warum genau, okay, Leute, warum, warum, warum braucht man
einen Triple-Node-Virtualisierungs-Cluster daheim, wenn man am Ende gar nichts da drauf
betreibt, also ich hab ja kein Problem damit, wenn einer ein Triple-Cluster-Node-Virtualisierungs-Cluster
daheim betreibt, wenn er dann darauf auch VMs betreibt, aber da ist ja nix drauf, ich
mein, selbst das hier ist jetzt nicht wirklich viel, aber egal, aber ich hab 4 Nodes, die
all meine Virtualisierungen machen, also sind die in einem Cluster, aber ich hab sie nicht
in einem HA-Modus, was bedeutet, ich hab keine HA-Virtual-Maschinen, aber ich bekomme trotzdem
die Vorteile eines Clusters, wie Maschinen, die sich umdrehen, sie umdrehen, sie umdrehen,
aber ich habe mich entschieden, keine HA-Virtualisierungs-Maschinen zu machen, Haley, Aku, Archie, Haley, Archie,
all of these run Kubernetes, und wir werden darüber sprechen.
Okay, er hat einen Triple-Node-Proxmox-Cluster, um darauf dann ein Kubernetes-Cluster laufen
zu lassen, alles klar.
Das ist für HA, also eine Sache, die ich jetzt nach über 15 Jahren im IT-Business
gelernt habe, ist, übertriebenes HA, ohne den Bedarf für HA, sorgt meistens für mehr
Ausfälle als ohne HA, also HA ist High Availability, wenn ich überlege, wie viele Probleme wir
hatten, rein durch die Existenz von High Availability-Maßnahmen, die dann letztendlich auch zu Problemen
geführt haben, wäre an manchen Stellen keine High Availability wahrscheinlich besser gewesen.
Und High Availability, ohne dass man das wirklich, wirklich braucht, ist meistens keine gute
Idee.
Also, zum Beispiel, zum Beispiel, wenn man daheim sitzt, hat seine Kiste hinter sich
stehen, will ein paar VMs drauf betreiben.
Und man steht jetzt vor der Wahl, hey, betreibe ich da einfach 3 VMs drauf und gut ist, hänge
eine externe Festplatte dran, mache ab und zu mal ein paar Backups und sollte wirklich
mal was kaputt gehen, brauche ich halt mal eine halbe Stunde, was zu restoren oder aber
sollte wirklich die komplette Kiste einen Kurzschluss haben und kaputt gehen, dann brauche
ich halt mal 3-4 Tage, bis ich Ersatz-Hardware habe, aber ich habe immer nochmal ein Backup.
Oder, also das versus, ich baue mir 3 Server daheim hin und mache es super krass kompliziert,
sodass ich mich mindestens am Tag 2-3 Stunden drum kümmern muss, dass meine Infrastruktur
überhaupt funktioniert.
Also, es ist meistens, achja, und wie viele Probleme bekomme ich dadurch, das ist eigentlich
das, was ich sagen wollte, ganz vergessen, und wie viele Probleme bekomme ich dadurch,
dass ich alles hochverfügbar gemacht habe.
Also, von Interconnect-Problemen zum Beispiel, Interconnect-Probleme ist eigentlich das größte,
die größte Fehlerquelle bei High Availability.
Also, du hast ja normalerweise, wir nehmen mal was ganz, wir nehmen mal was ganz Klassisches
an, mal was ganz Klassisches.
Du hast einen Netzwerkservice, wir reden gar nicht von Storage und sowas, genau, was ganz
Simples, sagen wir mal, du hast einen Loadbalancer, du hast einen Loadbalancer, ganz klar, simpler
Netzwerkservice, ich mache mal kurz ein bisschen Musik an, wenn ich es finde, du hast ein Netzwerkservice,
also du hast einen Loadbalancer, Cluster, so, ein Cluster muss, Chat, ich weiß, es ist
erst der 1.9.50 und ihr seid alle noch besoffen, aber wie viele Clusternodes brauchst du mindestens,
damit du überhaupt sinnvollerweise einen High Availability Cluster aufbauen kannst?
Drei, das ist korrekt, der Chat ist auch schon High IQ morgens um 9.50, das ist richtig,
drei.
Warum brauchst du drei?
Naja, um die Chance zu minimieren, oder um die, um die, um die Fehler zu minimieren,
dass wenn mal zwei Nodes sich nicht einig sind, wer jetzt der Masternode ist.
Malen wir das mal kurz auf, der dritte Node muss übrigens auch gar kein vollwertiger
Node sein, aber gehen wir jetzt mal von aus, also du hast drei, machen wir das anders,
machen wir das mal irgendwie, das ist, sieht ein bisschen aus wie so ein Emote jetzt, aber
so, du hast drei, du hast drei Loadbalancer Nodes und wie verbindest du die jetzt miteinander?
Du hast hier, du hast hier nen Switch, also nur um zu zeigen, dass auch simples High Availability
nicht so einfach sein muss, du hast hier nen Switch, jetzt könnte man ja auf die Idee
kommen, naja, wir verbinden die Dinger mit dem Switch und dann funktioniert das schon,
das funktioniert auch, jetzt hast du aber das Problem, dass der Switch hier ein Problem
hat, dass das, dass die Netzwerk-Config hier irgendwie kaputt ist, oder sagen wir mal sogar,
dass der Switch kaputt ist, oder was auch immer, irgendwie, irgendwie gibt das Netzwerk
technisch Probleme, so und was passiert jetzt, ja, was passiert jetzt, naja, das hier ist
ja nen Cluster, das ist, welche, was auch immer man da verwendet jetzt, ja, aber das
funktioniert alles ähnlich, also das hier ist ja quasi ein High Availability Cluster,
der nach außen eine Cluster-IP hat, also sagen wir mal, alle Loadbalancer zusammen
haben hier 192.168.5.1 oder so und jetzt ist das Ding, aktuell ist der hier der Meinung,
er ist der Masternode, jetzt geht das Netzwerk kaputt, so, Netzwerk ist trocken, jetzt ist
das Ding, was machen die Teile denn jetzt, die stellen fest, der Masternode stellt fest,
oh fuck, ich sehe ja keine anderen zwei Nodes mehr, also sind die ja wohl kaputt, und der
hier denkt, ich sehe ja auch keine anderen zwei Nodes mehr, also, also sind die wohl
kaputt und der denkt das auch und im Endeffekt, wenn du nicht aufpasst, hast du mal ratzfatz
auf einmal alle Clusternodes, die der Meinung sind, sie sind jetzt Master, sind jetzt der
Masternode, weil sie müssen ja davon ausgehen, sie sind der Masternode, weil die anderen
zwei sind ja kaputt, sie selbst sind nicht kaputt, weil sie selbst wissen ja, oder es
kann auch umgedreht sein, so nach dem Motto, hoch, ich bin jetzt kaputt, aber meistens
läuft es dann darauf raus, dass du mehrere Masternodes hast, Netzwerk kurz geruckelt
und auf einmal hast du drei Masternodes und es geht nichts mehr danach gescheit.
Deswegen, damit du überhaupt gescheit High Availability machen kannst, musst du eigentlich,
hier Inter, brauchst du noch einen extra, also die einfachste Variante wäre tatsächlich,
man würde noch einen Interconnect Switch hier unten drunter machen, ja, würdest du
noch einen Interconnect Switch machen und würdest die irgendwie nochmal da drüber
verbinden oder aber du verbindest die wirklich alle nochmal miteinander, kannst du auch machen.
Und da sieht man schon, selbst so eine simple Hochverfügbarkeitslösung, wo man denkt,
kann doch nicht so schwierig sein, einen Netzwerkservice hochverfügbar zu machen,
ist fehleranfälliger, wenn man es nicht richtig macht, als ein einzelner Service und da kann
man ganz andere Fehlerquellen bekommen, als man so denkt.
Also einfach nur drei Netzwerknodes aufsetzen und sagen, oh krass, Hochverfügbarkeit ist
jetzt alles viel besser, das ist wahrscheinlich über längere Sicht mehr kaputt durch die
Hochverfügbarkeitsmaßnahmen, wenn man sie nicht richtig umsetzt, als wenn man einfach
eine Node fire and forget hinstellt.
Also da muss man aufpassen, das ist gar nicht so, also das sieht immer, Raid ist ein weiteres
Thema, viele Leute denken sich, ach komm, ich will ja nicht, dass meine Daten weg sind,
wenn eine Festplatte kaputt geht, also machen wir ein bisschen Raid im Nass.
Als erstes muss man sagen, offensichtlicherweise ist Raid für Backupzwecke nur bedingt geeignet,
weil wenn ich eine Datei aus Versehen lösche, dann ist die weg, auf dem Raid, das Raid geht
noch, aber die Datei ist weg.
Oder wenn ich irgendeinen Verschlüsselungs-Trojaner oder sowas habe, der den File-Share, ich meine,
ich muss mal Logitech kurz starten, weil meine Tastatur keine richtigen, was ist das jetzt
hier?
Ich will einfach nur, dass meine Tastatur die richtigen RGB-Sachen anzeigt, ganz toll.
Geil, jetzt habe ich den Chat zugemacht, weil ich die Maustasten gedrückt habe, nice.
Ja, also das nächste ist Raid, viele Leute denken sich auch, sie machen Raid, weil Raid
viel hochverfügbarer ist, Raid ist nicht dazu da, dafür zu sorgen, dass die Daten
nicht verloren gehen, sondern Verfügbarkeit zu garantieren, also genau dafür.
Allerdings denken sich viele, wir machen Raid an, dann sind wir sicherer drauf, also aus
Versehen löschen, schützt sich Raid nicht davor und irgendwelche Verschlüsselungs-Trojaner,
die deine File-Share verschlüsseln, schützt sich Raid auch nicht davor.
Raid schützt sich einzuladen davor, dass wenn dir die Festplatte abbraucht, dass das Service
weiterhin verfügbar bleibt und selbst dann hast du Probleme, weil viele Leute verwenden
Raid 5, viele Leute verwenden Raid 5 und Raid 5 hat so ein paar Probleme.
Zum Beispiel, ich glaube das ist nicht der Richtige, und zwar, wenn wir jetzt mal hier
sagen, Raid 5, Number of Disks, 3, 10 Terabyte, Calculate, nein das ist nicht das was ich
haben will, das will ich haben, das will ich haben, also Raid 5, 10 Terabyte Platten sind
denke ich relativ normal, also 3, das ist ja das was viele Leute verwenden, so wir gucken
uns jetzt mal irgendwie Seagate, Ironwolf, 10 Terabyte an, was die für eine Fehlerrate
hat, dass wir auch was realistisches da mal eingeben, seht ihr das irgendwo?
Leute ich bin blind, hier, 10 hoch 5, 10, ok, also, das ist so ein normales Setup, da sieht
man schon, also so geil ist das selbst in der kleinsten Ausführung nicht, guck mal,
wir haben ein Raid 5 mit 13 Terabyte Platten, also nicht mit 13 Terabyte, sondern mit 3,
10 Terabyte Platten, und jetzt geht eine Platte kaputt, das bedeutet bei einem Raid 5 ja,
dass die anderen beiden Platten perfekt lesbar sein müssen, um die dritte Platte zu recoveren,
und wir sehen schon, bei der Fehlerrate haben wir nur eine Chance von 85%, dass das fehlerfrei
recovert, 85%, also man könnte jetzt sagen, hey, 85% ist ja schon mal nicht verkehrt,
aber, also würdet ihr in den Fahrstuhl steigen, wenn ihr wüsstet, zu 15% könnt ihr abstürzen,
also ich nicht, ich würde mir das wirklich gut überlegen, ob ich damit fahren würde,
weil 15% ist ganz schön viel, so, aber nichts, unabhängig davon, es kommen ja Leute noch
auf blöde Ideen, zum Beispiel die Anzahl der Platten in ihrem NAS zu erhöhen, in viele
NASs passen, in viele kleineren NASs passen 5 Platten rein, oder, 3 ist das mindestens,
4 von 5 Platten, aber passt mal auf, wenn man mal 4 Platten, 27%, da wird schon langsam
kritisch, also da würde ich mir wirklich überlegen, will ich wirklich meine Daten da
drauf legen, das ist bei weitem nicht so geil, wie man sich das vorstellt, was man machen
kann ist Raid 6 verwenden, Raid 6 ist dann deutlich, deutlich resistenter, aber man verliert
auch mehr Speicherplatz, dafür hast du schnelle Reads, muss man sich einfach nur mal im Hinterkopf
behalten, also oftmals hat man mehr Probleme, das war mir nicht bewusst, weil du hast, ja,
viele denken da nicht dran, viele denken Raid 5, easy, gar kein Problem, aber ist es nicht,
du hast, was hast du für Platten drin?
Es geht um den Rebuild in dem Fall, und dass der Rebuild nicht funktioniert, ja ja, also
dein Raid funktioniert, dein Raid funktioniert erstmal weiterhin, halt ziemlich degraded
und kaputt, aber es funktioniert weiterhin, aber wenn du Rebuilden willst, sodass dein
Raid wieder komplett intakt ist, musst du ja die anderen Platten nahezu perfekt lesen
können, dass du Rebuilden kannst, weil du musst ja quasi die dritte Platte Rebuilden
aus den anderen 2, und dazu müssen die ja alle lesbar sein, und wenn du dann ein Problem
bekommst, dass das Ding im Rebuild den Geist drauf gibt, bzw. Sektoren nicht lesbar sind,
dann war es das halt mit dem Rebuild.
Also wichtig ist vor allem die Größe der Platte und was die angeben für Fehlerrate.
Also du hast zum Beispiel, wenn du 10TB Platten verwendest, so eine 0815 Platte hier, wie wir
gerade geguckt haben, 10TB, hast du tatsächlich eine 20 oder 21%ige Chance, dass dein Rebuild
nicht funktioniert.
Das heißt nicht automatisch, dass du nichts mehr von diesem Raid runter bekommst, weil
es funktioniert ja mit 2 Platten auch noch, aber du hast halt vielleicht Leseprobleme,
ja.
Und wenn du Rebuilden willst, kackst du dir halt im Zweifelsfall ab.
Was bestimmt denn die Read Error Rate, das was dein Festplattenhersteller angibt?
Guck hier.
Du guckst dir einfach rein, was dein Festplattenhersteller, hier, Non-Recoverable Error Rate Max, einer
in, ja, da, 15 Nullen hinten dran.
Das klingt wenig, aber 10TB ist halt ganz schön viel Speicher.
Und das dann in Kombination aus mehreren Drives, wo alles fehlerfrei funktionieren muss, ist
die Chance, dass dein Raid fehlerfrei rebuildet, tatsächlich, 21%, dass es in die Hose geht.
Und das will man dann nicht haben.
Ja, das sind alles so Sachen, worauf ich letztendlich raus will, bevor wir uns das Video jetzt weiter
angucken.
Oftmals macht man sich mit Hochverfügbarkeitsmaßnahmen, oder besser gesagt mit vielleicht nicht ganz
zu Ende gedachten Hochverfügbarkeitsmaßnahmen, mehr Probleme, als gar keine Hochverfügbarkeitsmaßnahmen,
so blöd es klingt.
Zumal man sich ja um den ganzen Kram auch kümmern muss, ja.
Wie werden große NAS-Systeme gesichert?
Große NAS-Systeme sind meistens keine, ähm, wir schieben sechs Platten rein und machen
Raid 5 drüber.
Die machen dann, also, gibt natürlich verschiedene Abstufungen, also wenn du ein komplettes Storage-System
kaufst, was natürlich auch als NAS fungieren kann, das ist dann quasi so ein eigenes Rack,
was du kriegst.
Die sind intern oftmals, tja, in mehreren Stufen kann man das glaube ich am besten beschreiben.
Die großen Storage-Systeme sind intern meistens in mehrere Stufen aufgeteilt, ja.
Du hast dann Sachen, die, du hast dann quasi SSD-Cache mit drin, also meistens hast du
so drei Stufen.
So nach dem Motto Daten, die oft gebraucht werden, sind halt auf SSDs, die nächste Stufe
sind schnelle Platten und dann hast du vielleicht noch eine dritte Stufe irgendwie Stand-by-Platten
oder sowas.
Also du hast dann meistens sogar die Möglichkeit, ein großes Storage-System, dich zu entscheiden,
wie schnell soll das Ganze sein, dementsprechend teuer ist es, beziehungsweise dementsprechend
knapp ist der Speicher dann auch und du kannst dich auch entscheiden, was du für eine, ähm,
ja, Redundancy-Strategie, also für Ausfallstrategie fährst.
Dann machst du zum Beispiel sowas wie RAID 10, ist relativ beliebt, RAID 10 ist, also
RAID 10 ist quasi RAID 1 über, ne, nicht, dass ich jetzt Mist erzähle, ist RAID 10
ein RAID 1 über zwei RAID 0s oder ist es ein RAID 0 über zwei RAID 1, ich glaube es
ist ein RAID 1 über zwei RAID 0s, ne.
So Sachen wie RAID 10 ist da beispielsweise recht beliebt, allerdings auch nicht über
das ganze System, sondern immer nur über Teile und das unten drunter handelt dann halt
die Storage-Firmware.
Und ansonsten, wenn es noch ein größeres NAS-System ist, wenn du noch kein komplettes
Storage-System hier gekauft hast, wenn es quasi ein größeres NAS-System ist, dann
musst du dir halt überlegen, was du machst.
Du kannst zum Beispiel sowas nehmen wie RAID 50 oder sowas, ne, nicht RAID 50, erzähl
Mist, keine Ahnung, was man da am besten nimmt.
Du hast oftmals, du hast oftmals bei solchen Sachen auch mehrere Standorte und dann hast
du zweimal das gleiche NAS-System, was permanent über irgendwelche Glasfaserverbindungen gesynkt
wird.
Das kann dann aber die jeweilige Storage-Firmware, also bei den ganz großen Storages ist es
so.
Ich kann es dir zum Beispiel sagen, bei uns ist es so, wir haben an zwei verschiedenen
Standorten in Frankfurt haben wir Storage-Systeme stehen und die haben eine Dedicated-Glasfaser-Darkfiber-Verbindung.
Darkfiber heißt übrigens nur Darkfiber, weil die Dinger normalerweise rumliegen und
nicht benutzt werden.
Und die haben quasi eine Dedicated-Sync-Verbindung zwischen den Standorten nur für das Storage.
Dann hast du schon mal ganz andere Probleme, aber auch viele Probleme nicht mehr.
Ja und das Wichtigste ist, dass man tatsächlich ein Backup hat.
Die ganz teuren, die ganz super teuren Storage-Systeme, die kamen früher beispielsweise in Kombination
mit einer Tape-Library.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ihr sowas schon mal gesehen habt.
Die haben dann automatisch gebackupt.
Ja, sowas hier, wartet mal, das ist heute glaube ich nicht mehr so angesagt, aber ich
kenne das.
Ja, Tape-Library, da hast du Magnetbänder, wo automatisch gebackupt wurde.
Und das ist relativ high IQ dieses Ding, das rotiert und dreht auch teilweise die Bänder,
dass sie nicht verkleben und sowas.
Da sind wir aber schon im wahnsinnig teuren Enterprise-Storage-Segment.
Du hast dann quasi ein Storage- und ein Backup-System als Tape-Library nebendran.
Es hat was, ich war ja früher, als ich noch beim Provider gearbeitet habe, bin ich ja
morgens immer durch unsere Rechenzentren in Frankfurt gegangen und habe geguckt, ob alles
in Ordnung ist.
Und ich kann euch sagen, so eine Tape-Library, das hat was Meditatives, wenn man da vorsteht.
Da kannst du ohne Probleme eine Viertelstunde reingucken und du siehst eigentlich nichts,
außer so einen komischen Arm da rumfahren.
Du kannst ohne Probleme eine Viertelstunde reingucken, ohne dass es dir langweilig wird.
Da reden wir jetzt aber halt auch schon von, ich weiß gar nicht, was sowas kostet, ich
würde auch mal sagen, so komplette Storage-Sachen, da sind wir schon im Millionenbereich wahrscheinlich.
Mit ordentlichem Ausbau, keine Ahnung, was sowas kostet mit Storage und Backup-Library
und allem.
Naja, so, so werden meistens richtig große, professionelle Storage-Systeme gebackupt.
Heute weiß ich das nicht mehr, ehrlich gesagt, weiß ich nicht, wie das gemacht wird.
Ich kenne das noch zu Zeiten, wo ich beim Provider gearbeitet habe, da gab es so Sachen
wie Tape-Library beim Storage dabei, beziehungsweise zum Storage passend.
Wie man das heute macht, ehrlich gesagt, keine Ahnung.
Also, ich kenne bloß zwei Sachen, Sync zwischen mehreren Standorten auf die gleichen Storage-Systeme
über eine eigene Glasfaser, gemietete Glasfaserleitung, Infrastruktur und halt Backup über Tape-Libraries.
Was anderes kenne ich nicht, es gibt bestimmt noch mehr Varianten.
Ja, wir haben auch noch was, wir haben auch noch was, also, wie gesagt, ich guck mir das
immer noch gerne an, am besten in zwei Brandzonen, am besten ist, wenn du unterschiedliche Standorte
hast, ich meine, klar, theoretisch kannst du es weitertreiben und sagen, ja, zwei Standorte
in der gleichen Stadt sind auch blöd, guck mal, dass du zwei Standorte hast auf unterschiedlichen
Teilen der Welt und dann fünf Standorte auf unterschiedlichen, man kann es immer noch
weiterspinnen.
Das ist ja tatsächlich eines der Vorteile von dieser ganzen Cloud-Geschichte.
Das ist zum ersten Mal jetzt, dass jeder die Möglichkeit hat, wenn er denn will und ein
bisschen Geld in die Hand nimmt, wirklich seine Services hochverfügbar aufzubauen.
Das hattest du ja vorher nicht, wer konnte sich vorher, nee, das ist tatsächlich in
dem Fall ein Backup, weil der Sync ist meistens asynchron.
Also es ist kein Backup für historisch irgendwie, wie sah es aus vor 48 Tagen, aber es ist meistens
ein asynchrones Backup, das heißt, wenn jetzt was kaputt geht, kannst du das Backup direkt
wieder zurückspielen, das Letzte, wenn du Pech hast, dass es nicht eine Minute vorher
gelaufen ist, aber meistens läuft das zweimal am Tag oder so und einmal nachmittags, einmal
nachts oder irgendwie sowas, ist ja die Frage, wie man es einstellt.
Du hast jetzt zum ersten Mal die Möglichkeit, einen Service aufzubauen mit den ganzen Cloud-Providern
und Serverless-Geschichten, die es heute gibt, die wirklich hochverfügbar ist und auch theoretisch
irgendwelchen Kriegenstand halten würde, wenn du es überträgst, also mal angenommen, man
hätte jetzt wirklich Bedenken, dass hier die Bombe einschlägt in Frankfurt, ich möchte
aber, dass mein Service weiterläuft, ich könnte heute mit aktueller Cloud-Technik mein Service
so weit aufbauen, dass er nicht nur super performant überall auf der Welt läuft, sondern
ich könnte auch dafür sorgen, dass er weiterläuft, obwohl der Main-Server in Frankfurt vielleicht
kaputt ist.
Du kannst heute Datenbanken verteilt über die Welt machen, du kannst heute so Sachen
wie Anycast-Loadbalancing machen, relativ easy über Cloud-Provider, also dass quasi
die Kunden in Asien den Service in Asien verwenden, die Kunden in NA und die aus Europa, also
dass die quasi auch zum Nächsten hinkommen, also kannst heute tatsächlich auch als Nicht-Rechenzentrumsbetreiber
der Millionen in Infrastruktur steckt, deine Services relativ easy super hochverfügbar
aufbauen, dass sie theoretisch wirklich Bombenangriffen standhalten würde auf verschiedene Teile der
Welt.
Das ging vorher nicht so, früher hättest du dir deutlich mehr Gedanken machen müssen,
entweder hättest du das selbst bauen müssen oder du hättest halt gucken müssen, dass
du über mehrere Hoster verteilt irgendwie deine Infrastruktur aufbaust mit Umschaltmechanismen
und dann wird es trotzdem problematisch bei sowas wie Anycast-Loadbalancing, weil das machst
du mal nicht einfach so selbst, kannst du gar nicht selbst, weil du bist ja kein Provider,
du hast ja kein eigenes BGP-Netz und sowas, also da darfst du auch keine Sachen announcen
einfach so als so nach 15 vm-Mieter, also du kannst als normaler User nicht einfach
Anycast-Loadbalancing machen, kannst DNS-Loadbalancing machen, aber Anycast wird schwierig.
Also Anycast ist, dass du eine IP auf mehreren Teilen der Welt hast, also zum Beispiel, bevor
ich jetzt hier lange vor mich hin labere, zum Beispiel der Klassiker, der Google-DNS,
den Google-DNS, guck mal, ich hab einen Ping von 14, ihr könnt davon ausgehen, ich geh
wahrscheinlich nach Frankfurt irgendwo, wenn ich den Google-DNS anpinge.
Wenn ich den Google-DNS anpinge aus China, na gut, keine Ahnung, China ist immer ein schlechtes
Beispiel aus, sag mal, ich bin jetzt in New York und ping den Google-DNS an, dann hab
ich aber auch nur 14 Millisekunden Latenz, wie kann das sein?
Ja gut, ganz einfach, den Server gibt es einfach schlicht und ergreifend, bzw. die IP gibt
es einfach mehrfach auf der Welt und über geschicktes Routing, bzw. dass man sagt, hey,
die Route ist jetzt billiger oder die Route ist jetzt kürzer, kommt man immer bei der
IP raus, die näher an einem dran ist.
Und das ist halt eine Sache, das kannst du nicht als 0815-Server-Mieter von irgendwie
drei VMs machen, sowas.
Das funktioniert nur, wenn du quasi ein Provider bist, wenn du BGP-Netze announcen kannst,
Routen announcen kannst, dann funktioniert das und das kannst du nicht, glücklicherweise,
sonst wäre das Internetlaufen kaputt, wenn das jeder machen könnte und für solche Sachen
brauchst du irgendeinen Provider, brauchst du einen Cloud-Anbieter, der das supportet.
Und sowas ist heute aber easy für jeden möglich, also ihr könnt heute relativ einfach mit
einem Cloud-Load-Balancer, sagen wir bei Google zum Beispiel, mit dem Google Cloud-Load-Balancer
könnt ihr total easy sowas hier machen, Anycast IPs, nur eure Services weltweit, aber egal,
so viel mal zu Cloud-Geschichten.
Battlefield 3-Zeiten, hey, mir würde es ja reichen, ich will Battlefield 3-Zeiten gar
nicht zurück.
Auch wenn das eine geile Zeit war, also ich hätte vielleicht gerne so die Mentalität
der Leute und den Daily-Battlefield-Grind mit Leuten zurück, aber Battlefield 3 nicht
zwangsläufig, weil ich bin der Meinung, sie sollen eben mal ein ordentliches neues Battlefield
machen und nicht so einen Roar-Krepierer wie 2042.
Ich könnte mir durchaus vorstellen, dass ich mehrere Stunden am Tag wieder Battlefield
spiele, wenn es halt was taugt.
Ich spiele MMO, ich spiele in MMO zur Zeit wieder mehrere Stunden am Tag, gar kein Problem,
aber das Game muss halt was tauchen, was Battlefield 2042 nicht macht.
Ja, OVH, das ist da, wo es gefackelt hat.
Tja, so sieht's aus.
So, also jetzt gucken wir uns das Video mal fertig an.
Ich habe jetzt ganze 2 Minuten 50 geguckt und habe irgendwie eine halbe Stunde über
Cloud-Technik, High-Availability und sonst was gelabert, aber so mögt ihr das ja, ne?
Was?
Was ist das da unten?
Windows!
Was zum?
Was ist das wieder für ein Scheiß hier unten, man?
Ist das genug?
Sieht ein bisschen so aus, ja?
Warum blendet es da unten so eine Kackleiste ein?
Alter!
Kubernetes!
Wir testen jetzt mal was, wir testen jetzt mal was.
Wir testen jetzt mal was, wir testen jetzt mal was, ob das in Firefox auch so ist.
Katy Perry lässt sich Essen mit Lieferando liefern.
Alter, okay.
Man kann diesen ganzen, man kann das Internet eigentlich ohne Adblocker gar nicht verwenden.
Schon geil, oder?
Ach ja, im Firefox geht das.
Guck mal, im Firefox kann ich rüber wechseln, kein Problem.
Im Chrome nicht.
Also demnächst müssen wir wohl Firefox verwenden.
Ja, wozu er die ganzen Sachen hat, wird er wahrscheinlich immer noch nicht erzählen.
Okay, wir machen mal ein bisschen weiter.
Also wir haben bis jetzt gelernt, eigentlich hat er seine Virtualisierungsinfrastruktur,
um darauf ein Kubernetes Cluster laufen zu lassen.
Okay, das heißt, die eigentliche Frage ist, was lässt er alles auf seinem Kubernetes Cluster
laufen?
Ja, und was läuft jetzt da drauf?
Mal ganz davon abgesehen, by the way, also ich meine, was hat er denn hier insgesamt?
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10, ja, ich meine, 10 VMs ist jetzt auch nicht so, als wäre
das, wenn das was Minimales ist, jetzt super krass zu handeln oder so.
Alter, the fuck?
Eine Kubernetes Testumgebung für seinen Kubernetes Cluster, der dann wieder dafür da ist, um
Kubernetes zu sein?
Okay, weiter, weiter, was, was, was, was macht der, was läuft denn darauf jetzt?
Okay, nass.
Was, was, was, was mache ich denn mit S3 daheim?
Ich überlege gerade den Anwendungszweck für S3 bei mir daheim, okay, ja, okay, okay, okay,
ja, auf jeden Fall, ja yes, ja okay, ja okay, ja okay, ja ja ja, ja okay.
DNS, as well as network-wide ad blocking. It started out as just network-wide ad blocking,
but then PiHole added the local DNS feature, which is really nice for me because I host
lots of things in my internal network and I like to refer to them by name. It also helps
out with certificates and a whole bunch of other things. But I actually have three instances
of PiHole and you're thinking, what the heck, how can you have three DNS servers? I do.
It's pretty complicated and I do this for a specific reason. So my first PiHole instance
is a virtual machine. It's this one right here. My second PiHole instance is also a
virtual machine. It's one that you don't see right now. My third PiHole instance is a tiny
Raspberry Pi Zero. The way that I've organized these is that my primary DNS is this machine
right here, a virtual machine. My secondary DNS is actually a VIP or a virtual IP that's
load-balanced between two PiHole instances. So it's load-balanced between a virtual machine
and my Pi Zero. Why did I do that? One, I wanted to learn how to use keepalive.de. So
I wanted to be sure that if my whole entire server rack shut down, that my Pi Zero would
still be serving out DNS requests. So that gives me a low power option when and if I
shut things down. Hey, is the internet down? So really, I have a primary DNS and a secondary
DNS, but the IP of the secondary DNS is a virtual IP that those two share. So when one's
down, it'll take over. When it comes back up, the virtual machine...
Ganz ehrlich, das kann man ja schon so machen. Es ist ja nicht, als wäre das jetzt irgendwie
so ein böses Setup, was man nicht verwenden darf. Ich frage mich halt einfach nur, warum
sollte ich mir daheim so einen Akt, so einen Aufwand machen? Ich meine, er könnte einfach
sein Raspberry Pi nehmen als primary DNS und gut ist. Also wenn er sicherstellen will,
dass alles noch funktioniert, was Namensauflösung angeht, auch wenn sein Rack ausgeschaltet
ist, dann nehmen wir halt einfach den Raspberry Pi standardmäßig. Wie gesagt, man kann
das machen, ist gar kein Ding. Kann man machen, wenn man üben will, ist ja alles in Ordnung.
Aber wenn ich mir überlege, an wie vielen Stellen da irgendwas hängen kann und du bist
erst mal drei Stunden am Debuggen, woran es jetzt hängt, es switcht irgendwie um, es
wurde nicht richtig announced, der Switch denkt immer noch, er muss dahin, dabei ist
die IP, da kann so viel schief gehen und du musst erst mal Stunden gucken, was ist es
denn jetzt?
So the way that I keep them in sync is by gravity sync. Gravity sync will not only
sync your block list across multiple instances, but it will also synchronize your local DNS,
which is super handy. So the way I have it set up is I have my primary DNS.
Wisst ihr, was ich habe? Ich habe gar kein Adblock-DNS mehr. Ich verwende halt uBlock
und ich habe auf meinem Router ein paar lokale DNS-Namen konfiguriert, so 20 oder so. Fertig.
Adblock-DNS verwende ich nicht mehr, seit es leider auf den meisten Seiten, die ich
verwende, nicht mehr richtig funktioniert.
Zum Beispiel Twitch kannst du damit nicht blocken, YouTube kannst du damit nicht richtig
blocken, aber vielleicht geht YouTube wieder, aber die ganze Zeit lang nicht. Twitch hat
ja schon Probleme hier mit, im Browser, Adblocker.
Was ist das da unten, ja?
Okay, das skippen wir jetzt mal. Er hat gesagt, er benutzt kein DHCP von Pi-Hole. Dass er
kein DHCP nutzt, hat er nicht gesagt.
Er hat gesagt, er nutzt kein DHCP von Pi-Hole. Das hat er nicht gesagt, dass er kein DHCP
von Pi-Hole nutzt, hat er nicht gesagt.
Ja, ja, ja, das hat er ja oft genug erzählt, aber wofür? Du hast nichts Spannendes verpasst,
außer absoluter Overkill wieder.
Das ist ja nicht so, als hätte er die anderen zwei schon gebraucht.
Ich, ich mag Portainer nicht. Ich mach entweder Docker-Command-Line oder irgendeinen Docker-Compose-File,
wenn's was Einfaches sein muss und fertig.
Aber für mich gab es mehr in Kubernetes, als in Docker.
Also für mich war es sehr herausfordernd, meine Infrastruktur in Kubernetes zu managen
und dann eine andere Part der Infrastruktur mit der Plano-Docker-Art zu managen.
Also war es wirklich herausfordernd, diese beiden zu managen.
Wisst ihr, was deutlich weniger Challenge wäre für ihn? Einfach gar kein Kubernetes-Cluster.
Ich habe mich damals auf dieses Thema beschäftigt, insbesondere, wenn ich viel Automation auf
der Kubernetes-Seite habe und sehr wenig Automation auf der Docker-Nachfolger-Seite.
Also habe ich mich entschieden, alle Docker-Kontainer in eine neue, kleine Kluster zu migrieren
und jetzt läuft sie darin.
Aber lasst uns das mal ganz kurz durchreden.
Wie ihr seht, habe ich hier drei Kluster, einen genannt Local, einen genannt Cluster01
und einen genannt Cluster02.
Lass uns zu Local sprechen.
So this Local Cluster is dedicated to running Rancher.
That's it.
That's all that runs on.
By the way, Leute, wir haben die Hälfte des Videos durch.
Ich möchte das jetzt bloß noch mal, okay, nicht ganz, fast die Hälfte des Videos durch.
Ich möchte das nur mal unterstreichen.
Wir haben bis jetzt nur gesehen Infrastruktur und Infrastruktur-Management und das geht
auch noch eine Weile weiter, Infrastruktur und Infrastruktur-Management.
Wir haben noch in keinem Wort außer ganz kurz bei den Kameras drüber geredet, was
denn jetzt eigentlich darauf läuft, was man denn am Endeffekt dann auch wirklich benutzt.
Also was läuft darauf, was man eben am Endeffekt benutzt und einen Mehrwert dadurch hat.
Aktuell haben wir nur Infrastruktur und Infrastruktur-Management.
71 Deployments.
Ja, ich weiß nicht, was er da treibt, keine Ahnung.
Benutzt noch jemand Docker Swarm?
Ja, ja, es gibt Leute, die benutzen Docker Swarm, dort, wo ich mich beworben habe, nicht
dort, wo es jetzt was geworden ist, die benutzen noch Docker Swarm, haben sie mir erzählt.
Wie haha, wie fast alles.
wir werden darüber sprechen in ein paar Minuten, aber ich benutze die UI wirklich nur als das Dashboard für
all meine Kubernetes-Cluster. So, ihr könnt hier sehen, das ist nur mein Rancher-Cluster,
das läuft über K3S und ist nur für Rancher-Cluster verwendet. Dann haben wir Cluster 01, das ist
mein User-Workload-Cluster. Das ist, wo ich alles, was ich in Kubernetes runnen will,
läuft. Und das ist das gleiche Cluster, das ich schon seit ein paar Jahren runne. Es ist
nur gewachsen. Wie ihr seht, hatte ich mehr Noden, aber das ist das Schöne an Kubernetes. Ich
gebe mehr Noden, wenn ich aus Computer, Disk-Spaß oder sogar RAM runne, und es wird den Noden in
den Cluster hinzufügen und alles ausruhen und meine Services höchstwahrscheinlich erhältlich machen.
Sie werden endlich zu diesem Noden wechseln, so wie sie es brauchen. Aber in diesem Cluster,
wenn bei dem mal irgendwas nicht funktioniert, ist er erstmal fünf Stunden damit beschäftigt,
rauszufinden, an welcher Stelle es hängt. Mich würde interessieren, was läuft denn jetzt
wirklich drauf? Ja, es ist immer ganz besonders toll, das Monitoring-System auf der Plattform
laufen zu lassen, die es monitoren soll. Da kann ja nichts schief gehen. Was denn zum Beispiel?
Ja, okay, und was läuft hinter Traffic? Ich will einfach wissen, warum. Also,
was läuft denn jetzt da drauf? Okay, Home Assistant. Wahnsinn!
Ein ganzer Service läuft da drauf! Boah, Alter!
Ne, mir ist die Zeit nicht zu schade. Ich rattle ein bisschen drüber rum, das ist wunderbar.
Alter, wisst ihr, ich denke schon immer, bei mir ist es komplizierter und, ja, keine Ahnung,
unsinnig kompliziert schon im Vergleich zu dem, was viele haben. Viele Leute haben daheim eine
Fritzbox stehen, fertig, aus und es funktioniert wunderbar. Ja, damit bin ich nicht so ganz
zufrieden, dass ich zum Beispiel einen extra IoT-WLAN habe und ein paar unterschiedliche
Netze und so. Das ist ja schon mehr als die meisten Leute. Aber das ist einfach komplett
Kosten-Nutzen-Relation nicht gewahrt. Also, ich koste meine ich jetzt nicht unbedingt das Geld,
was das kostet. Ich glaube, die Hardware, die man da hat, ist auch teuer, aber vor allem der
Zeitaufwand. Also, der Aufwand für das, was man davon hat, steht in keinem Verhältnis.
Okay, jetzt kommt kubernetes-storage. Okay, ich will einfach wissen, was er da drauf
laufen lässt. Das ist ja wirklich was Neues.
Ja, ja, alles schön und gut, aber was läuft denn jetzt drauf?
Traffic ist tatsächlich nice. Den verwende ich auch gerne, allerdings nur, wenn man ihn
automatisiert konfigurieren kann. Traffic-Config von Hand ist echt der größte Abfuck überhaupt.
Naja, wie? Nur drei? Aber nur drei Reverse-Proxys ist aber zu wenig. Ich hätte gedacht, dass der
mindestens acht hat. Ihr habt Traffic verworfen, was macht ihr jetzt? Man gibt ja
ein paar klassische Variante, wie irgendein Nginx-Proxy. Also, ich mag ja persönlich
Kadi für einfache Sachen. Moment, wo sind wir hier? Okay, ich will einfach nur mal wissen,
was da wirklich drauf läuft. Habe ich auch eine Weile verwendet. Ist wirklich geil. Ist
wirklich geil für Leute, die einfach nur Container starten wollen oder einfach nur,
ich glaube, das ist irgendeine Vue.js Anwendung mit ein bisschen Express.js Backend und so.
Leute, die einfach nur mal starten wollen und ein paar Raspberry Pis pingen wollen bei sich daheim
und einfach nur wissen wollen, ist es up oder down, ist es gut? Mir haben leider ein paar
Kleinigkeiten gefehlt. Zum Beispiel, dass man so Sachen wie Festplattenbelegung nicht gescheit
überwachen kann damit, außer mit ganz vielen Tricks, dass du keine richtige History hast,
also kannst du auch nicht gucken, hey, wie oft wird denn der Plattenplatz beim Recorder knapp
und sowas, dass man nicht ordentlich Zertifikatablaufdaten überwachen konnte,
aber für eine simple Monitoring-Lösung up-down ist das wirklich nice. Ich habe jetzt daheim
tatsächlich Zabbix laufen, auch wenn ich Zabbix gerade vor der Konfiguration ja echt mega abartig
finde und auch von der Optik und dem Dashboard ist es nicht schön. Ja, na gut.
CheckMK habe ich mir nie wirklich im Detail angeguckt, weil die eh so ein komisches
Lizenzmodell hatten. Du kriegst irgendwie nur 20, 20 Hosts kostenlos oder sowas und
oder 20 Services irgendwie kostenlos und ansonsten kannst du die Community-Version
verwenden, die nichts mehr mit der normalen Version zu tun hat. Das hat mich alles ein
bisschen verschreckt bisher. Leute, Grafana, wisst ihr, was das Geilste an Grafana ist?
Das Geilste an Grafana ist, es sieht cool aus, wenn du was Cooles zeigen musst. Vieles
der Grafen, gerade die Standard-Dashboards sind komplett useless. Also ihr müsst euch
mal, warte mal, warte mal. Haben die eine Demo? Ich hab hier gerade nichts. Ich sag doch, das
ist Infrastruktur, um Infrastruktur zu verwalten hier. Node-Exporter full. Also, es ist leider
nicht gut. Also hier, du kriegst hier standardmäßig ein schönes Dashboard für den default Prometheus-Exporter
für Linux. Ganz ehrlich, das sieht cool aus, aber 95% der Graphs da drin sind komplett
useless. Die bringen dir überhaupt gar nichts im täglichen Benutzen und vor allem auch
nicht, um irgendwie Fehler rauszukriegen. Es ist praktisch, die Daten zu haben, wenn
du nicht weißt, was gewesen ist. Also wenn jetzt dein Service ruckelt und du weißt nicht
warum und du willst gucken, was ist, dann ist es tatsächlich schon praktisch, aber
wie gesagt, 95% der Graphs hier drin noch nicht einmal reingeguckt. Das Coole an Grafana
ist, es sieht gut aus, wenn der Chef ins Büro kommt und du kannst sein Grafana-Dashboard
zeigen. Hey, cool, nice. Aber ansonsten, es ist wirklich nicht einfach und es braucht
schon eine gewisse Hirnleistung dafür, um ordentliche, aussagekräftige Grafana-Dashboards
zu machen, wo auch sinnvolle Werte erfasst werden und die so aggregiert werden, dass
was Sinnvolles dabei rauskommt. Also irgendein Dashboard über die gleiche Metrik von 98
Systemen zu haben, irgendeinen Graph zu haben mit den Default-Settings über 98 Systeme
von der gleichen Metrik, bringt dir in der Regel nichts. Ja, du siehst, okay, hier sind
alle Server runtergegangen, aber was du ja oftmals wissen möchtest, ist dann zum Beispiel
die Kombination aus, ja, woran hat es denn jetzt gelegen, war der RAM voll, war das Netzwerk
irgendwie ausgelastet, gab es irgendwelche, wie viele aktive Verbindungen hatte ich und
das Ganze quasi so zu bauen, dass du dann auch was Sinnvolles daraus erkennen kannst,
ist wirklich nicht einfach in Grafana. Die Möglichkeiten sind da, aber einfach einen
Default-Dashboard drauf klatschen, ist es halt nicht mit getan. Dann hast du sowas
hier, wo ich mir denke, ja, nice, Server-CPU-Usage und jetzt, ist rot jetzt gut, ist rot jetzt
schlecht, sind Lücken gut, sind Lücken schlecht, blau wie, was, wo, man weiß es nicht und das
geht ja noch, da sind ja nicht mal viele. Das ist doch immer die Herausforderung von
Big Data. Okay, ich hätte jetzt, du hast recht, ich hätte jetzt Grafana nicht unbedingt Big
Data genannt, aber natürlich, wenn man cool sein will, das mache ich ab jetzt, das ist
eigentlich eine gute Idee. Wenn irgendwelche Grafana-Dashboards nicht ordentlich sind,
dass man damit anfangen kann, dann werde ich im nächsten Meeting auch mal sagen, das
ist die Herausforderung von Big Data. Das finde ich richtig gut, weil das klingt wichtig
und irgendwie zutreffend, ja. Das merke ich mir, das merke ich mir. Wenn wieder einer
ankommt und sagt, man, sind die Grafana-Dashboards scheiße, sage ich, so sind halt die Herausforderungen
von Big Data und dann sagt keiner was drauf, weil sich alle denken, was will denn Max
uns damit jetzt eigentlich sagen. Aber das ist gut, so habe ich das noch gar nicht gesehen.
Die Meinung zu Observium habe ich noch nie verwendet. Ich weiß, das ist glaube ich ein
Blog von LibreNMS oder so was, oder von OpenNMS. Ich habe ihn noch nicht verwendet. Das ist
für Netzwerkzeug wohl recht cool, so als generelles Monitoring-System wahrscheinlich
jetzt nicht so der Wahnsinn. Ich glaube, hauptsächlich geht das ja auch über SNMP, bei diesem ganzen
Zeug, was halt für Netzwerkgeräte gut ist, für Überwachung von Services, zur Überwachung
von Servern, von irgendwelchen Diensten ist SNMP jetzt nicht so das Geilste. Nagios, Leute,
Nagios. Ich habe ein weiches Herz für Nagios. Ich meine, ich würde heute nicht mal unbedingt
neues Nagios installieren, aber ich mag Nagios. Das liegt daran, dass ich mich während meiner
Ausbildungszeit um einen Nagios-Server kümmern musste, weil wie gesagt, meine Ausbildungszeit
war ja nicht, ich wurde ausgebildet, sondern ich musste irgendwas machen, ohne dass ich
wusste, was ich eigentlich machen muss und dann musste es irgendwie funktionieren, also
nicht, dass ich eine Ausbildung gehabt hätte in der Ausbildung so richtig. Und ich habe
mich da um Nagios gekümmert und ich mag auch die Nagios-Config. Du kannst ja in der Nagios-Config
auch Settings vererben und so was, das kann man richtig cool machen. Also ich mag Nagios,
auch wenn ich sagen würde, ich würde Nagios heute nicht mal wirklich neu einführen irgendwo,
wenn es natürlich auch ein bestehendes System gibt. Ich habe damals in der Ausbildung, kann
ich mich noch daran erinnern, wie hieß das Ding, wie hieß das Ding von Nagios, war das
der NRPE-Agent? War das NR, der Nagios-Agent, hieß das Ding nicht NRPE-Agent oder so? Ich
habe zumindest den Nagios-Agent damals selbst kompiliert noch für drei verschiedene Target-Systeme
und das war CentOS, Debian und jetzt kommt es, SUSE. Wir hatten damals noch SUSE für
Telefonanlagen und so was. Also nicht für die Telefonanlage selbst, sondern irgendwie
für die Verwaltungsgeschichte von Telefonanlagen. Es war SUSE. Da musste ich den Nagios-Agent
damals kompilieren für ein Ur-Ur-Ur-Ur-Ur als SUSE für den Debian und für Red Hat,
also CentOS. Und ich kann euch sagen, das war wahrscheinlich der ausschlaggebende Punkt,
warum ich SUSE nicht mag und bis heute nicht verwende und jedes Mal, wenn ich mit SUSE
in Kontakt komme, es mich abfuckt und ich nichts damit zu tun haben will. Kommt wahrscheinlich
daher. Und nochmal Fun-Fact zu alten Dingern. Dort, wo ich aktuell arbeite, haben wir auch
ein super tolles, nices Konstrukt und zwar, es gibt eine Datenbank-Software, das ist,
frag mich nicht, irgendein Oracle, irgendein uraltes Oracle. Also das Oracle, das ist so
alt, das Oracle, was da drauf ist. Leute, hattet ihr mal ein bisschen Plan von Oracle?
Wie alt ist Oracle? Was war das? 6, 8 oder sowas? Ne, nicht Oracle, Linux. 15? 15? 12!
Von wann ist Oracle 12? 2013? Ah, das ist noch ein bisschen neu. Irgendwie sowas hier.
10, 10 noch was. Zumindest, wir haben, mir läuft die Nase. Wir haben ein Red Hat System
laufen. Das ist ein, jetzt haltet euch fest, das ist ein Red Hat 6, getarnt als Red Hat
4. Oder Red Hat 5? Ne, es ist ein Red Hat 6, getarnt als Red Hat 4. Warum? Weil die
Datenbank, die da drauf läuft, ein Red Hat 4 System erwartet. Die guckt in ETC Red Hat
Release oder irgendwo rein, ich glaube ETC Red Hat Release ist es und wenn da nicht steht,
dass es ein Red Hat Enterprise Linux 4 ist, startet sie nicht. Das heißt, man hat ein
Red Hat 6 installiert, um darauf dann ein Red Hat 4 vorzugaukeln und Red Hat 6 ist ja
auch schon komplett out of alles, was es gibt. Und dieses System gibt es immer noch und dieses
System wird irgendwie einmal im Quartal eingeschaltet, um dort irgendwelche Daten noch rauszuziehen.
Sonst ist es aus. So, jetzt wird es aber echt mal langsam Zeit, dass er uns erklärt, was
er denn eigentlich da drauf benutzt. Also, Spoiler, ich kenne das Video nicht, aber ich
spoilere trotzdem schon mal. Wahrscheinlich nichts wirklich Relevantes.
Jemand, verwendet jemand von euch das Grafana Alerting? Das haben die ja eingeführt. Also
dieses Unified Grafana Alerting, das haben die ja eingeführt vor einem Jahr oder so
ungefähr. Ich habe da noch keinen bisher gehört, gesehen, der das verwendet und ich
selbst habe es auch noch nicht verwendet. Mich würde mal interessieren, wie das funktioniert.
Ja, das ist es. Grafana ist cool drauf zu gucken, aber die Graphen
so zu machen, dass man auch was handfestes, aussagekräftiges hat, ist tatsächlich schwierig.
By the way, man könnte einfach sowas simples wie Syslog verwenden, wenn man wirklich Logs
zentral einsammeln will, aber ich glaube, das ist zu einfach.
LOKI ist nicht Elasticsearch. Von welchen ist LOKI nochmal? Elk ist Elasticsearch, oder?
Und LOKI ist jetzt von welchen? Ach, da sind das auch die Grafana Leute. Es gibt ja so
zwei, drei konkurrierende Sachen, was das angeht. Haben die InfluxDB Leute, haben die
nicht auch irgendein Logging-Kram? Übrigens, ich bin der Meinung, man braucht
das daheim gar nicht. Wer hätte das gedacht? Du brauchst daheim eigentlich gar keine zentrale
Log-Auswertung. Wie viele Kisten hast du denn daheim? Und bei mir ist es schon ein bisschen
komplizierter. Also, ich habe hier hinter mir eine Kiste stehen. Darauf virtualisiert
ist zwei VMs. Einmal eine Ubuntu-Kiste mit ein bisschen Zeug drauf und einem Zabbix und
mein Home Assistant. Und dann habe ich noch acht, neun Container drauflaufen. Also, die
Kiste habe ich. Nehmen wir mal die VMs als einzelne Kisten, sagen wir drei. Den Host
und die zwei VMs, drei. Dann habe ich im Keller einen Raspberry Pi. Für die Kamera noch einen
Raspberry Pi. Man könnte sagen, ja, vielleicht möchte ich von meinem Router noch sammeln.
Sind wir bei sechs. Für den 3D-Drucker, den Raspberry Pi, sind wir bei sieben. Im Wohnzimmer
könnte man sagen, ich möchte vielleicht da, wo man Fernseher aufnehmen kann, haben wir
acht. Ich glaube, das war es. Also, mit sehr viel gutem Willen komme ich auf acht Systeme
bei mir daheim. Und das ist wahrscheinlich schon deutlich mehr. Also, wo ich eventuell
Logs einsammeln will. Von meinen Desktops und Tablets will ich ja kein Logs einsammeln.
Sagen wir mal acht Kisten. Ich habe wirklich sehr großzügig gerechnet. Dafür brauche
ich kein irgendwie krasses Log-Auswertungs-Zeug. Wo es sinnvoll sein könnte, ist Log-Auswertung
in Form von, hey, ich habe jetzt Beispiels. Gehen wir mal zum Beispiel von außen unten
im Keller für die Heizung. Das Programm, was die Heizungsdaten ausliest, kackt ab und
zu ab. Und der einzige Weg, es gescheit mitzubekommen, dass es abkackt bzw. nicht abkackt, sondern
Connection-Probleme hat, ist, wenn es Errors in das Log schreibt. Okay, das kann man sich
überlegen, ob man das nicht einsammelt, dass man in seiner Monitoring-Lösung quasi es
mitbekommt, wenn das Auslesen der Heizung nicht funktioniert. Das ist okay. Aber normalerweise
eine Log-Auswertung daheim bei acht Kisten, wozu? Außerdem brauche ich keine Log-Auswertung,
das kann ich immer noch machen mit irgendeinem Node-Exporter. Einfach greppen, gucken, ob
in dem Log was drin steht. Wozu brauche ich da eine super, ich brauche keine zentrale
Log-Sammlung für daheim, ich brauche keine zentrale Auswertung, kein Full-Text-Search
über meine Logs und solche Geschichten daheim. Das sind acht Nodes und bei acht, also ich
habe schon viel. Die meisten Leute haben daheim vielleicht, wenn es hochkommt, ihr nass, fertig
aus. Da kannst du dich im Zweifelsfall schlicht und ergreifen, wenn du wissen willst, was
mit den Hosts ist, kannst du dich einfach per SSH drauf einloggen und ins Log gucken.
Sowas soll gehen, ja. Natürlich, wenn das Ding Probleme hat und komplett am verrecken
ist und ich mich nicht mehr drauf einloggen kann, ist das mit Logs schwierig. Also es
ist auch nicht so, als kommt es jeden Tag dreimal vor. Also ist auch wieder so ein Ding,
wo ich bedenke, eigentlich brauchst du es daheim nicht. Was empfiehlst du für eine
Monitoring-Software? Das kommt ganz entscheidend darauf an, was du machen willst. Es gibt
da mittlerweile mehr, also fangen wir mal an. Läuft das Zeug bei dir bzw. ist das irgendwie
deine eigene Infrastruktur? Weil wenn nicht, wenn du irgendwelche Cloud-Services verwendest,
könnte es sogar sein, dass das, was der jeweilige Anbieter bietet, voll und ganz ausreicht.
Notifications, wenn was down geht, irgendwelche Connection-Limits oder sowas. Vielleicht reicht
das, was der Anbieter out of the box bietet voll und ganz aus, da braucht man schlicht
und ergreifen gar nichts und nimmt einfach das, was der Anbieter hat. Wenn man das verwenden
kann. Ansonsten ist natürlich die große Preisfrage, was will man machen? Was will
man monitoren? Möchte man hauptsächlich so klassische Sachen wie ISUP, ISDOWN monitoren,
RAM-Auslastung, CPU-Auslastung, Response-Times, vielleicht noch Zertifikate, die ablaufen
und sowas. Dann ist das ja so ganz klassisches Monitoring, wie man das seit 30 Jahren macht.
Dann würde ich sowas nehmen wie Zabbix oder irgendein der Nagios-Abkömmlinge von Ichinga
und CheckMK und was nicht alles. Gibt nicht persönlich Zabbix. Wer auf Windows steht
und sich den Müll geben will, kann auch PRTG verwenden. PRTG selbst ist ziemlich gut, was
ich gesehen habe. Habe ich nie was großartig mitgemacht, aber das, was ich gesehen habe,
ist tatsächlich nicht schlecht. Aber es ist halt Windows-Only und Windows-Only ist halt
nichts was man haben will. Also entweder, wie gesagt, für so klassische Sachen sowas
wie Zabbix, Nagios oder eben CheckMK, Ichinga, sowas in dieser Richtung gibt. Ich persönlich
mag da Zabbix, auch wenn die Config ein bisschen eklig ist. Also wenn du so klassische Sachen
monitoren willst, dann sowas. Wenn es ganz simpel daheim sein soll, auch was in der Richtung.
Genau. Das ist auch sehr nice, wenn du einfach nur wissen willst, ist mein Raspberry Pi
ab, ist mein Raspberry Pi kaputt oder ist der Webservice auf dem Raspberry Pi noch erreichbar.
Dann kannst du Uptime Kuma nehmen, das ist wirklich nice. Das hört aber schon auf, wenn
du so Sachen überprüfen willst, wie ist die CPU-Auslastung am Limit oder läuft meine
Festplatte voll. Das kannst du damit schon nicht mehr machen. Aber es ist cool, wenn
man wirklich nur was ganz simples, Service Up und Down braucht, ist Uptime Kuma das beste,
was man so daheim verwenden kann. Sieht dann so aus. Gibt es eine schöne Demo zu. Gucken
wir uns das jetzt mal an. Irgendwann, demnächst. Demo Ends. Admin 123456 Massive. Was? Das
ist tatsächlich die allersimpelste Variante. Das kann man selbst, Docker-Container starten
gut ist. Da kann ich jetzt sowas hinzufügen, wie zum Beispiel, du kannst ablaufende Zertifikate
überprüfen, aber du hast keine schöne Übersicht darüber. Du bekommst bloß ne Meldung, irgendwie
glaube ich dann 20 Tage, aber du siehst es auch im Webinterface nicht. Machen wir mal
hier. Wir nehmen jetzt einfach mal HTTPS. Google.com. 60 Sekunden. Erweitert. Benachrichtigung
ablaufendes Zertifikat. Blablabla. Speichern. Was? Achso, ja. Google. Speichern. So. Und
dann hat man sowas hier. Hat man ne coole Übersicht drüber. Wenn die simplen Sachen,
also wenn das einem ausreicht, ist das wirklich cool? Mir reicht's nicht ganz. Es macht so
90 Prozent von dem, was ich für mein Heim-Monitoring bräuchte, macht es. Allerdings nicht alles.
Ja, zum Beispiel hätte ich gerne nen Graph über die Festplatten-Auslastung von meinem
Fernsehrekorder drüben und sowas. Das geht hier halt nicht gescheit. Und man sieht beispielsweise
auch nicht, wann die Zertifikate ablaufen. Man bekommt bloß eine Benachrichtigung, wenn
die Zertifikate ablaufen. Man kann allerdings sich Zertifikat-Infos irgendwie anschauen.
Weiß ich nicht, wo das war. Ach hier, da. Das sieht man, man kann sich dann auch die
Sachen ausgucken. Genau, das ist was anderes. Das hat mit Zertifikat nichts zu tun. Was
ich jetzt halt nicht sehe, ist beispielsweise alle meine Domains schön in nem Graph zusammen,
wann die Zertifikate ablaufen. Und sowas. Also, es macht 90 Prozent von dem, was ich
hab, will allerdings nicht alles. Und ich glaube, das hier wird auch nicht orange, wenn
die Zertifikate, das war auch ne Sache, die mich gestört hat. Mal angenommen, Zertifikatablauf
ist auf 5 Tage runter, dann wird das hier nicht orange. Sondern wirklich erst, wenn
der Check fehlschlägt, sondern man kriegt bloß ne Benachrichtigung. Das waren ein paar
Sachen, die mir nicht so gefallen haben im Detail. Also für simple Sachen ist das wunderbar
für daheim. So, also. Das ist so für so Up-Down-Monitor. Wie gesagt, wenn du ein bisschen was umfangreicheres
haben willst, nimm sowas wie Zubbix. Oder eines der Nagios Abkömmlinge. Ich mag Zubbix.
Grad, weil sich Zubbix auch gut mit anderen Sachen integrieren lässt mittlerweile. Dann,
die nächste Variante, was du vielleicht überprüfen willst. Also, du müsst jetzt mal in den
Chat schreiben, was du eigentlich genau monitoren willst. Die nächste Variante sind Metriken,
zum Beispiel Performance-Metriken von deiner Anwendung. Oder vielleicht auch von deinem
Load-Balancer oder von deinem Reverse-Proxy oder sowas. Da kommen wir dann in Richtung
Timeseries-Datenbank und Prometheus. Beziehungsweise Grafana als Visualisierung. Wenn du zum Beispiel
eigene Anwendungen hast und wissen willst, was die gerade so intern treiben. Wie oft
läuft der Garbage-Kollektor? Wie viele User sind eingeloggt? Wie viele Connections pro
Sekunde? Und solche Geschichten. Das kriegst du ja nicht durch eine einfache Abfrage von
ist der Port up oder down raus. Das heißt, die Software muss das irgendwie kommunizieren.
Das heißt, sie muss das irgendwie exportieren. Also die Software muss irgendwie das mit der
Umwelt mitteilen und dann brauchst du eine Software, die diese Informationen einsammelt.
Und da hat sich eigentlich Prometheus die letzten Jahre über ziemlich etabliert. Prometheus
schreibt dir das ein und mit Grafana kannst du dann schöne Dashboards über deine Anwendungsmetriken
machen. Du kannst mit Prometheus natürlich auch Linux-Systeme überwachen, weil es gibt
einen Linux-Node-Exporter, der dir so Sachen wie Festplattenbelegung, CPU-Auslastung und
sowas exportiert. Da hast du aber dann wieder das Problem, du hast dann ganz super viele
Daten von allen deinen Linux-Systemen. Dich interessiert ja aber eigentlich nur, in Anführungsstrichen
sagen wir mal, Festplatte wird voll. Du musst dir mit Prometheus, wenn du klassisches Systemmonitoring
machst mit Prometheus, also dieses klassische Schwellwert ist über, unter, Port ist up
und down. Das kannst du mit Prometheus machen, ist aber ein bisschen umständlicher. Gerade
Port ist up oder down ist ziemlich umständlich. Du brauchst noch einen extra Exporter, der
die Checks für dich macht und diesen Exporter sammelst du dann ein. Dann musst du irgendwie
gucken, wo setze ich Schwellwerte, wie mache ich meine Benachrichtigung. Das ist in so
klassischen Monitoring-Systemen wie Zabbix und so alles mit drin, geht damit super easy.
Ein popliches, ist der Port up oder down in Prometheus mit einem ordentlichen Grafana-Dashboard
plus Alerting ist ziemlich kompliziert versus wir klicken einfach dreimal auf weiter und
legen den Host an und haben dann eine Anzeige. Also man merkt man, das ist nicht wirklich
dafür entworfen worden. Es geht, aber du musst dir das Monitoring mit Prometheus eher
selbst zusammenbauen für solche klassischen Sachen. Das nächste was du hast, was Monitoring
angeht, ist Netzwerk. Netzwerk ist ein komplett eigenes Thema, kannst du natürlich auch mit
Zabbix und sowas machen. Aber wie gesagt, es geht meistens über SNMP, da gibt es dann
solche Sachen wie LibreNMS, wobei ich das auch einfach in Zabbix packen würde, wenn
ich eh schon Zabbix hätte. Also wenn du Netzwerkinfrastruktur überwachen willst, ist das auch nochmal eine
Wissenschaft für sich. Und dann der letzte Punkt, das ist das, was wir gerade schon hatten.
Vielleicht möchtest du auch Logs überwachen und da bist du dann im Bereich von Elasticsearch
und Auditbeat und Logbeat und Loki und wie heißt das von InfluxDB das Zeug. Keine Ahnung,
da gibt es auch zig Varianten für. Also, es steht und fällt damit, lange Rede, kurzer
Sinn, was du monitoren willst, was du am besten dafür verwendest. Ja, eigentlich ganz klassisch,
Auslastung, Festplattenbelegung auf einen Blick. Ja, dann würde ich sowas wie Zabbix
verwenden. Du kannst dir auch Prometheus angucken, ob du damit besser klarkommst, aber du musst
halt da relativ viel selbst zusammenstöpseln. Ja, du brauchst beispielsweise, du musst Noderexporter
installieren auf allen deinen Linux-Kisten, dann musst du den einsammeln lassen und dann
musst du irgendwie dir ein ordentliches Dashboard dafür bauen und dir überlegen, wie du dir
Nachrichtigungen schickst. Es ist mit Abstand die flexibelste Lösung, aber braucht halt
ein bisschen Handarbeit und man muss sich vieles selbst ausdenken. Oder du nimmst sowas
wie Zabbix oder CheckMK oder, tja, ganz ehrlich, hierzu kann ich nicht wirklich viel sagen,
weil ich es noch nie richtig verwendet habe, aber das gibt es auch. Also, ich würde wahrscheinlich
Zabbix nehmen. Das ist wohl eher was für Netzwerke. Habe ich auch noch nicht verwendet,
aber ich glaube, das ist was, was aus Libre oder Free oder OpenNMS entstanden ist und
das ist hauptsächlich für Netzwerküberwachung über SNMP. Du kannst, glaube ich, mit Agents
das auch machen, aber ich würde wahrscheinlich mal Zabbix angucken, wenn es ein bisschen
umfangreicher ist. Also, wenn du nicht nur zwei VMs hast, ich finde da Zabbix ganz gut.
Muss man sich ein bisschen einarbeiten, bis man das geplickt hat, aber dann ist ganz okay.
Und das Schöne an Zabbix ist, Zabbix kann mittlerweile auch recht gut andere Sachen
anzapfen. Du kannst in Zabbix auch Prometheus NodeExporter integrieren. Ein bisschen umständlich
und leider nicht so schön, wie man es gerne hätte. Die Graphen im Zabbix sind jetzt auch
nicht so geil. Das heißt, wenn man wirklich super-advance Graphen braucht, könnte man
auch einen Grafana noch zusätzlich betreiben. Ja, Monitoring ist tatsächlich so ein bisschen
komplizierteres Thema und ein eigenes Thema für sich. Es gibt ein paar simple Monitoring-Lösungen,
sowas wie Uptime KUMA. Da bist du aber schon über die Grenze von dem, was das Tool kann,
raus, weil du willst Festplattenbelegung. Es gibt leider kein, wie soll man sagen, so
simples, kompaktes, ein bisschen mehr Monitoring-Tool. Nicht super umfangreich, aber ein bisschen
mehr. Gibt es leider nicht. Also, ich fände es ja cool, wenn irgendwann mal einer was
bauen würde, was so die Basics abdeckt plus ein bisschen was, was vielleicht noch eine
Übersichtsseite hätte mit ein bisschen IP-Verwaltung dabei. Gibt's, gibt's nicht, aber vielleicht
habe ich da auch irgendeinen Denkfehler, dass das gar keinen Sinn macht. Ja, kann auch sein.
Ja, also wie gesagt, stehen und verhält damit, was du eigentlich letztendlich überwachen
willst. So, next. So, wir gucken jetzt mal. Fertig.
Die Amis finde ich immer am geilsten, wie sie Prometheus aussprechen. Prometheus.
Soll ich euch mal was sagen? Wisst ihr, was auch cool ist und was viel einfacher geht
ohne extra Infrastruktur? SSH verbinden und ein Grab machen auf das Log-File. Ich meine,
das ist nicht so wirklich krasses Web 5.0 Cloud Native oder so, ja. Es skaliert auch
nicht diagonal und to the moon, aber so eine SSH-Verbindung und Grab auf ein Log-File funktioniert
in der Regel auch ganz gut.
So, das war's. Ich hoffe, es hat euch gefallen. Wenn es euch gefallen hat, lasst ein Abo da.
Wenn euch das Video gefallen hat, lasst ein Abo da. Wenn euch das Video gefallen hat, lasst
ein Abo da. Wenn euch dieses Video gefallen hat, lasst
der Infrastruktur verwaltet, sondern wirklich was benutzt.
Oh, HomeKit, Bonkreis.
Das kenne ich, da bin ich auch überlegen das zu verwenden.
Und, und, das Jahr des Linux-Desktops.
Ja, gibt es.
Ja, ok.
Heimautomatisierung macht er.
Ja, das ist nicht schlecht.
Ok.
Ach, ich dachte jetzt, der synchronisiert damit vielleicht seine Notizen oder so, aber nein, nein, der verwaltet damit weiterhin seine Infrastruktur.
Ja, toll.
Geil, ein LinkTree-Klon, dafür brauche ich natürlich definitiv meinen eigenen Kubernetes-Cluster.
Das läuft nur im Kubernetes-Cluster, sowas ist nicht denkbar, woanders drauf zu hosten.
Ein URL-Shortner muss natürlich auch unbedingt im Kubernetes-Cluster laufen.
Ok, Plex.
Ja.
Der hat immer noch nichts laufen, der hat nichts laufen auf seiner Hardware.
Der hat im Endeffekt HomeBridge, das ist eh auf dem Desktop, der hat HomeBridge, einen LinkTree-Klon und einen URL-Shortner, fertig.
Drei und ein paar statische Webseiten, einen URL-Shortner und einen LinkTree-Klon.
Warum zum Teufel hat er drei oder vier Kubernetes-Cluster daheim?
Ich mache überhaupt kein internes CI, CD mehr. Wenn ich irgendwas habe, dann ist das wahrscheinlich eh für irgendwas Öffentliches und dann nutze ich GitHub Action.
Also das einzige Projekt, wo ich tatsächlich ein bisschen was laufen habe, ist das für das Elektroauto.
Es läuft über GitHub und das baut ab und zu neue Container über GitHub Actions und pusht sie dann.
Jede Zeit, wenn ich ein bisschen Code verpflichte, pushe ich es ab, es wird ein paar Tests auf dem Code laufen, es wird Docker-Container gebaut, es wird sie in eine Registrie einbauen
und dann wird es Kubernetes sagen, dass sie das Container in die Kubernetes-Cluster einbauen.
Und dann nimmt Kubernetes über und zieht einen Pod runter, verwendet ihn mit einem neuen Pod, mit einem neuen Range.
Und jetzt stellt euch mal vor, der pusht ein Git-Change und da passiert einfach nichts.
Da muss er an 800 Stellen gucken, was ist jetzt eigentlich das Problem?
Drei Stunden, drei Stunden, Kinder locker drauf dann.
Er hat sicherlich viel gelernt, ich sage nichts, das habe ich ganz am Anfang dazu gesagt.
Sollte es rein zu Lernzwecken sein, vollkommen in Ordnung.
Ja, nicht mit drei Kubernetes-Clustern daheim.
Okay, es ist im Prinzip exakt das, was ich vermutet hatte. Er lässt die Infrastruktur zum größten Teil sich selbst verwalten.
Also er hat quasi Infrastruktur, um Infrastruktur zu verwalten, um Infrastruktur zu haben.
Also nicht wirklich irgendwas.
Tja, im Prinzip das, was ich gedacht habe.
Ich lag falsch, AMD hat ein großes Problem.
Okay, komm, wir haben schon lange kein Video vom Auer mehr geguckt.
Wir sind ja immer gut gemacht, das gucken wir uns jetzt an.
Was erzählt der Bauer zu AMD?
Für mich hat sich das eh erledigt. Ich habe jetzt meinen neuen PC am Start mit Grafikkarte und sonst was. Da werde ich bestimmt keine AMD-Karte mehr reinstecken, die trotzdem schlechter ist.
Oder zumindest, was heißt schlecht, schlechte Performance-Technik schlechter, Stromverbrauchstechnik schlechter, wahrscheinlich nicht.
Gucken wir mal. Also, der Auer.
Hallo zusammen, herzlich willkommen zu einem weiteren Video. Erstmal ein kurzes Dankeschön an euch beim letzten 7900XX Video, das wir gemacht haben, wo ich bei einer Karte die Wärmeleitpaste getauscht habe.
Habt ihr extrem viel kommentiert und mich dementsprechend dazu verleitet, dem Ganzen nochmal mehr auf den Grund zu gehen.
Deswegen danke für die ganzen Kommentare an dieser Stelle.
Ich habe mich die ganze Woche mit diesem Thema beschäftigt und es ist definitiv eskaliert.
Und ich kann jetzt schon vorwegnehmen, dass es für AMD auf jeden Fall katastrophal wird.
Also, ich dachte erst am Anfang im ersten Video, es ist tatsächlich nur ein Problem vielleicht mit Anpressdruck, Wärmeleitpaste.
Hetzter Werbung, alles klar.
Alles nicht der Fall, aber wir gehen in die Beschreibung.
Nach dem letzten Video haben sich bei mir insgesamt 48 Leute gemeldet mit dem Hotspot 100°C Problem. Davon waren 29 horizontal verbaut, 19 davon bewertet.
Mit dem was?
Und wenn man das schon mal 19 horizontal verbaut, 100°C Problem. Davon
Mit dem was? Ich habe keine Ahnung, um was es geht.
Nach dem letzten Video haben sich bei mir insgesamt 48 Leute gemeldet mit dem Hotspot 100°C Problem. Davon
Mit dem Hotspot 100°C Problem. Okay, ich habe keine Ahnung, um was es geht. Ich vermute, die Grafikkarte wird zu warm.
29 horizontal verbaut, 19 davon vertikal.
Und wenn man das schon mal sieht, dann muss einem eigentlich schon klar sein, dass das Problem nicht so einfach zu lösen sein kann,
wie der Kühler zieht an der Karte irgendwie durch Schwerkraft und deswegen ist der Anpressdruck schlecht.
Das habe ich mir zumindest mal dann direkt gedacht.
Dann haben extrem viele davon mir angeboten, mir ihre Karte zu schicken.
Ich habe dann so ein bisschen aussortiert, um unterschiedlichste Fälle abdecken zu können.
Erstmal vielen Dank an Robin, Thomas, Christian und Bastian, von denen ich jetzt vier Karten hier habe.
Drei davon habe ich quasi abgekauft, zwei haben eine RTX 4080 im Austausch bekommen
und einer hat eine 7000Hz XTX in einem anderen Design als Austausch bekommen,
beziehungsweise bekommen sie jetzt noch, weil die Karten kamen jetzt erst bei mir an.
Einer davon bekommt einen Wasserkühler dann auf die Karte gebaut, weil damit wird das Problem auf jeden Fall gefixt sein.
Ich habe dann erstmal alle vier Karten durchbeschriftet, also das ist zum Beispiel Karte C,
dass ich da auch nichts irgendwie später vertausche und immer weiß, welche Karte ist welche
und ich dann auch immer zuordnen kann, wo wir genau sind, bei welchem Step vom Testing.
Grundsätzlich alle von den Karten...
Nur, dass ich jetzt check, um was geht's? Also die Grafikkarte wird zu warm.
Das ist wahrscheinlich...
Vertikaler Einbau? Okay, das muss ich mir jetzt mal angucken. Ich weiß nicht, ich check's noch nicht.
Ich habe alle vier Karten eben in unterschiedlichen Szenarien, sei das jetzt horizontal, vertikal,
dann vertikal Testbench oder zum Beispiel auch...
Okay, also jetzt habe ich glaube ich verstanden, die Grafikkarte wird zu warm
und er will jetzt gucken, ob das daran liegt, ob die Grafikkarte irgendwie schepp eingebaut ist
oder ob es in irgendeiner Lage besser wird, oder?
Angewinkelt. Also eine Karte davon kam aus einem Gehäuse, das ist ein Fractal-Gehäuse,
wo die Karte leicht positiv geneigt ist.
Und das sind eben die ganzen vier Karten und da sieht man schon vier Unterschiede.
Ich überlege gerade, meine Karte ist weder positiv noch negativ geneigt, glaube ich.
Ich hoffe ich.
Ich habe ja auch den Grafikkarten-Ständer darunter.
Also meine Grafikkarte ist ja so fett.
Man sieht das hier gerade.
Ja.
Hallo Leute, hier ist der Max. Max ist gut.
Also, guck mal, man sieht das ja hier schön.
Meine Grafik, hier, guckt mal.
Da ist ein Ständer.
Erkennt ihr das? Da ist ein Ständer unten an der Grafikkarte.
Hier.
Guckt da. Seht ihr das?
Hier unten.
Hier.
Da ist ein Ständer an der Grafikkarte, das hier nicht durchhängt hinten.
Soweit sind wir schon, Leute.
Du musst Grafikkarten abstützen, dass sie nicht durchhängen.
Aber man sieht es hier irgendwo noch ein bisschen besser.
Hier.
Hier, guckt da unten. Hier, da ist das Ständer darunter.
Seht ihr hier?
Schon Wahnsinn, du musst Grafikkarten abstützen heutzutage.
Verschiedene Szenarien, aber alle das gleiche Problem
mit 110°C Hotspot-Temperatur.
Also, war schon irgendwo klar, ganz so einfach.
Okay, wir machen mal ein bisschen weiter.
Ich bin noch nicht ganz dahinter gestiegen.
Als allererstes habe ich alle vier Karten stock getestet,
d.h. alle vertikal auf meiner Testbench,
so wie ich das normalerweise mache.
Und ich wollte erst mal quasi Software als Problem auswählen.
D.h. ich habe einmal Gaming getestet.
Wisst ihr was, wir machen einfach das,
wir gucken uns einfach das Fazit an.
Dann weißt du, um was es geht.
10 Minuten und dann auch noch mal Nüchterung nach nur einer Minute.
Direkt wieder auf 110°C.
Zu dem Zeitpunkt bin ich mir sicher,
dass mangelnder Anpressdruck definitiv nicht mehr das Problem sein kann.
Denn mit anderen Schrauben,
der anderen Feder auf der Rückseite und so weiter,
das konnte einfach nicht mehr sein.
Also zurück zum Thema Vaporjammer.
Und wir hatten ja...
Was für ein Ding? Rauchkammer?
Jetzt mit dem Washer Mod und auch mit den gekürzten Standoffs...
Oder was ist denn Vaporjammer?
Immer horizontal getestet, also immer so.
Und jetzt habe ich mich natürlich dann noch mal gefragt,
wie hält sich das Ganze dann vertikal.
Also das muss man ja auch wieder abdecken,
um zu schauen, hat sich da irgendwas verändert oder nicht.
Aber auch vertikal mit hohem Anpressdruck...
Das finde ich äußerst praktisch, ehrlich gesagt.
Dieses 12-Volt-Dings-8-Pin-Kabel mit der Anzeige.
Das finde ich sehr nützlich, das Teil.
Eigentlich das Ergebnis wie vorher.
Anpressdruck, Wärmeleitpaste, damit komplett auszuschließen.
Ich habe also wieder meinen selbstgebauten
horizontalen Teststand verwendet
und diesmal die Karte dabei hingelegt,
um also wieder vertikal zu testen.
In diesem Zustand sollte die Karte wieder gute
oder zumindest ähnliche Ergebnisse erreichen wie im ersten Video.
Wir sehen im Chart nach knapp 10 Minuten
eine GPU-Temperatur von 62°C
und eine Hotspot-Temperatur von 86°C.
Das ist zwar nicht toll,
aber ein gutes Stück von 110°C entfernt.
Und die Karte taktet normal.
Lüfter laufen also bei 1750 Umdrehungen.
Ich habe die Karte dann im laufenden Betrieb
ganz vorsichtig aufgestellt,
um wieder horizontal zu testen.
Ich habe währenddessen weiterhin aufgezeichnet.
In GPU-Z dauert es ein paar Sekunden
und dann sehen wir plötzlich einen Anstieg
sowohl der Lüftergeschwindigkeit
als auch der Hotspot-Temperatur.
Im Chart zeichnet sich hier ein deutliches Bild ab.
Innerhalb von nur drei Minuten
steigt die Hotspot-Temperatur auf 110°C an.
Die Lüfter laufen auf 2800 Umdrehungen
bzw. 100%
und trotzdem kann die Karte den Takt nicht halten.
Hinzu kommt, dass die GPU-Temperatur ebenfalls ansteigt
und nicht nur die Hotspot-Temperatur.
An diesem Punkt könnte man natürlich vermuten,
dass der Kühler nicht richtig sitzt
und durch die horizontale Montage
der Kühler nach unten gezogen wird
und dadurch der Kontakt jetzt wieder schlechter ist.
Das lässt sich aber relativ einfach ausschließen,
denn ich habe die Karte jetzt einfach wieder hingelegt.
Und jetzt kommt das Interessante.
Es verändert sich nichts mehr.
Die Temperaturen bleiben schlecht
und es lässt nur eine Erklärung zu.
Die Vaporchamber selbst ist das Problem.
Natürlich habe ich auch...
Was? Okay, ich habe keine Ahnung.
Was ist eine Vaporcham...
Vaporchamber?
Gibt es das auch auf Deutsch das Wort?
Was soll das sein? Eine Dampfkammer?
Was?
Was genau hat das jetzt mit...
Vaporchamber?
Ach!
Die Vaporchamber sind quasi das,
wo die Kühlrippen durchlaufen, oder wie?
Okay, der Kühler.
Irgendwas mit dem Kühler.
Wie kann das sein,
dass AMD sowas nicht merkt?
Vielleicht haben sie es gemerkt
und haben sich gedacht, scheiß drauf.
Performance bleibt weiterhin schlecht.
Das heißt, Problem komplett eingegrenzt.
Und zwar auf den Kühler
beziehungsweise die Vaporchamber selbst.
Die Vaporchamber ist nichts anderes
als eine riesige flache Heatpipe.
Das bedeutet, wir haben da drin eine Flüssigkeit
und wir haben in der Regel einen abgesenkten Innendruck.
Und durch den Innendruck kann man eben steuern,
an welchem Punkt die Flüssigkeit verdampfen soll.
Dadurch, dass dann die Flüssigkeit verdampft,
zum Beispiel im GPU-Bereich,
kondensiert die wieder am kalten Bereich,
also dann unter den Finnen,
und dann kann das wieder zurücklaufen
zum heißen Bereich.
Und so entsteht quasi eine Zirkulation,
also ein Kreislauf zwischen
verdampfen und kondensieren,
der dann das ermöglicht, die Karte zu kühlen.
Die Menge an Flüssigkeit...
Okay, das hätte er mal am Anfang erzählen können.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was eine Vaporchamber ist.
Aber gut, das ist interessant.
Das sind wenige Milliliter, also wirklich wenig.
Und man muss es eben perfekt auslegen
zwischen dem Innendruck, den man hat,
der Menge an Flüssigkeit, dem Volumen usw.
und natürlich auch dem Geflecht,
das sich innen in der Vaporchamber befindet,
was dann eben durch die Kapillarwirkung
dann erlaubt, dass die Flüssigkeit
wieder zum heißen Bereich
zurückbewegen kann.
Leute, IQ 5 Punkte gestiegen heute Morgen schon wieder.
Das bedeutet, es gibt eigentlich nur zwei mögliche Ursachen
bei der Vaporchamber selber.
Also entweder ist sie nicht richtig ausgelegt,
d.h. irgendwas passt vom Innendruck nicht
oder von der Menge an Flüssigkeit, die drin ist.
Oder wir haben einfach
einen kapitalen Konstruktionsfehler
bei der Vaporchamber selber,
was die wahrscheinlichere Variante ist.
Denn wir sehen ja auch,
die Vaporchamber ist nicht symmetrisch.
Die hat eine relativ komplexe Struktur hier hinten.
Und es ist naheliegend, dass
in eben der einen Ausrichtung
das Wasser nicht mehr ausreichend
zurückfließen kann zu der GPU
und damit die Vaporchamber an sich
kapituliert.
Durch das Verhalten, das wir sehen mit diesem Kippen und Zurückkippen,
dass es eben dann schlecht
bleibt, ist auch auszuschließen,
dass es z.B. die Oberfläche der
Vaporchamber ist. Also es liegt nicht daran,
dass hier irgendwie was uneben ist oder sowas.
Aber es ist schon blöd,
wenn die Grafikkarte
in der normalen
Montageposition
überhitzt.
Das ist schon
ziemlicher Müll, das ist schon ziemlicher Dreck,
den AMD da gebaut hat.
Das müssen sie doch gemerkt haben.
...der Fall, sondern es ist einfach
nur die Vaporchamber selbst.
Ich hatte jetzt leider nicht mehr die Zeit, das Ding aufzumachen
und zu schauen, ob innen drin irgendwie ein Materialfehler
vorliegt oder ob es einfach ein Konstruktionsfehler
an sich ist. Aber
das ändert an der Tatsache nichts,
dass der Kühler
das Problem ist. Und das ist natürlich jetzt für AMD,
ich kann es sagen, wie es ist, es ist ein riesen
Desaster. Denn man kann
sagen, wie es ist, die ganzen
MBA-Karten, also sag ich mal
dieses Referenzdesign von AMD hier,
die sind davon betroffen.
Zum großen Teil. Also nicht alle
davon, es gibt ja auch Karten, die funktionieren gut,
aber alleine, dass mich 48 Leute
an der Stelle haben... Aber warum merken die das nicht?
...problem haben,
zeigt, dass es ein riesen Problem ist.
Das bedeutet auch, das betrifft auch alle
Partnerkarten. Das heißt, alle, die das MBA-Design
haben, sei das jetzt eine Sapphire-Karte, eine Powercolor-Karte,
Asrock, was es alles
gibt, alle, die dieses Design
benutzen, die diesen Kühler haben, tendenziell
riesen Problem.
Also ich weiß auch nicht, wie
AMD da vorgehen will. Man kann jetzt
natürlich überlegen, ob man dann wartet, bis die Kunden
RMA machen, was aus meiner Sicht
bei dem Umfang des Problems
auf jeden Fall der falsche Weg wäre.
Und ich würde mal vermuten, das
einzige, was hier übrig bleibt, ist ein
kompletter Rückruf der kompletten
MBA-Serie. Und es betrifft dann eben nicht nur
die 7000 XT, sondern auch
die XT-Karten. Wenn man
dachte, das Problem bei
NVIDIA mit den Kabeln ist ein Problem,
dann kann ich euch sagen, das hier ist ein richtiges
Problem. Weil bei den NVIDIA-Karten
zum Beispiel, da waren das ja
fünf Fälle von irgendwie
100.000 Karten.
Hier sind das tausende Fälle.
Das ist ja...
Tausende Fälle von tausenden Karten.
Dieses Problem hier, das kann man gar
nicht fassen.
Ich bin froh, dass ich es jetzt nach dieser
Riesenzeit eingrenzen konnte.
Durch dieses Hin- und Herkippen.
So einfach das klingt.
Aber sich Stück für Stück daran zu testen und dann
wirklich alles auszuschließen und nur
noch dieses Ding als Problem übrig zu haben.
Hat mir mal wieder trotzdem Spaß gemacht.
Auch wenn das jetzt für AMD weniger spaßig
wird, weil der finanzielle Schaden,
die komplette Serie zurückzurufen,
oder wie auch immer das AMD handhaben möchte,
das wird sicher nicht so toll werden.
Da gibt es wahrscheinlich dann gleich morgen
eine Runde
Krisenmeeting bei AMD. Wobei,
ganz ehrlich, das gibt es nicht gleich morgen. Das ist ja Blödsinn.
Das wissen die doch schon.
Das wussten die wahrscheinlich vorher schon.
Kann doch nicht sein, dass
das Ding komplett durch die Lappen geht, oder?
Ich meine, die müssen doch
ihren Kramer auch im größeren Stil ausprobieren.
Übrigens auch daran denken, wie AMD
Marketing damals Nvidia gebashed hat mit dem Stecker.
Sollte man sich als Firma
in so einer Größe vielleicht überlegen, ob man sich zu solchen
Aussagen hinreißen lässt, wenn man dann selber
solche Probleme hat. Betrifft jetzt natürlich
auch Nvidia. Auch an eurer Stelle würde ich mich jetzt
nicht aus dem Fenster lehnen und irgendwas zu AMD
sagen. Aber,
krasser Fehler von AMD.
Aus meiner Sicht Vapor Chamber.
Entweder Konstruktionsfehler oder Materialfehler.
Aber, Riesenproblem
bei diesen Karten.
Damit ist das Thema aus meiner Sicht geklärt.
Ich hoffe es hat euch gefallen.
Jetzt wissen wir Bescheid.
Leute, gut,
dass ich doch viel zu viel
Geld ausgegeben habe.
Für eine 4090.
Die bleibt
wenigstens schön kühl. Die war
viel zu teuer. Ich hätte mir davon wahrscheinlich 2
AMD oder 3 AMD Karten kaufen können.
Aber gut, dann hätte ich auch
nicht die Leistung dafür gekriegt.
Wie häufig gab es
Krisenmeetings bei deinem noch jetzigen
Arbeitgeber?
Das ist schwer zu sagen.
Das schwankt immer ein bisschen.
Je nachdem, wenn es Probleme gibt.
Also,
Okay,
sagen wir mal, so richtig
extreme Krisendinger
auch mit
Leuten aus dem Urlaub
zurückordern
und so, das gab es in den letzten Jahren
einmal.
Aber Krisenmeetings in Form von
Irgendwas ist kaputt gegangen
und
das gibt es natürlich öfter.
Aber so richtig Krise, das
wirklich krass am Arsch was war,
einmal, einmal die letzten Jahre über.
Das ist mir egal.
Das ist kein Thema.
Wenn mir es da nicht gefällt,
dann muss ich ja da nicht bleiben.
Dass es IT-technisch
überall an jeder Ecke neue Jobs gibt,
habe ich ja zur Zeit gemerkt. Aber es
geht alles dafür, dass es da eigentlich ganz nice ist.
Grafana-Board für Chat-IQ.
Hier geht's.
Also was bei mir,
beim jetzigen Arbeitgeber und ich vermute mal
auch beim neuen, da weiß ich noch nicht,
was da öfter passiert ist, nicht Krisenmeetings
in Form von
jetzt werden alle
einbestellt und es ist wirklich irgendwie
unternehmenskritische Sache oder so.
Jedes Mal, wenn was kaputt geht, wird sich das
im Nachhinein halt noch angeguckt. Was ist denn
passiert? Was ist denn gewesen? Das ist auch
eine Sache, die mir bei meinem aktuellen Arbeitgeber
ein bisschen auf den Keks geht, dass so
Retrospektiven eigentlich nicht
wirklich dafür benutzt werden,
um jetzt zu gucken,
okay, was war denn und was können wir
denn verbessern, sondern eher
so ein bisschen dazu benutzt werden, so nach dem Motto
wem können wir es denn in die Schuhe schieben?
Ja genau, wem kann man es in die Schuhe schieben?
Und da kommt dann
meistens nichts Sinnvolles bei raus.
Wird
ja auch noch ein bisschen unterstrichen dadurch,
dass oftmals Leute diese
Meetings
einberufen und leiten müssen,
die von der Materie so gar keine Ahnung
haben. Und obwohl man ihnen genau sagt,
was jetzt wie wo ablauftechnisch gewesen
ist, schreiben sie dann trotzdem was Falsches hin und sowas.
Aber nicht mal absichtlich, sondern
einfach, weil sie keine Ahnung von der Thematik
haben. Die sind richtig lost bei sowas.
Und ansonsten, Krisenmeetings
ist was kaputt. Man wird angerufen
so nach dem Motto, hier
weißt du was dazu? Das kommt natürlich schon öfters
mal vor. Ja, ich mein,
wir haben so viele Systeme,
da geht öfters mal was kaputt.
Allein schon durch die pure Anzahl ist da
mal irgendwo immer mal was.
Und jeder tut natürlich
bei seinem System, als ist es der Weltuntergang,
wenn jetzt gerade dieses System kaputt ist.
Am geilsten war immer noch, ich hab irgendwann
mal in unser E-Mail-Postfach geguckt, also
ein altes E-Mail-Postfach,
was eigentlich überhaupt nicht mal verwendet
wurde. Hab ich da reingeguckt
und irgendwann hab ich da mal gesehen, da kam eine Mail rein,
das System steht nicht zur Verfügung.
Da hab ich mir gedacht, weißt du was?
Ich bin jetzt einfach mal nett und
antworte da drauf, dass das
eigentlich komplett die falsche Stelle ist und
selbst wenn das die richtige Stelle wäre,
es unklar
ist, was das System
ist, also welches System es geht.
Und da kam dann als Antworter
drauf, ja das System, mit dem
wir täglich arbeiten, Ausrufezeichen.
Und da hab ich mir gedacht, okay,
dann kümmer ich mich jetzt da doch nicht drum.
Das System.
Das ist
einfach zu erklären,
das ist der Unterschied
zwischen
Theorie und Wirklichkeit.
Auch wenn du Systeme
redundant ausgelegt hast, können die
durchaus Probleme haben. Auch wenn
du es natürlich so baust, dass du möglichst
wenig Probleme haben wirst,
aber gegen irgendwelche
Bugs oder
schlicht ergreifend Fehler,
kannst du auch mit einem
redundanten System manchmal nichts machen.
Wenn jetzt einer zum Beispiel
neue Software-Version deployed
und auch
wenn schön getestet wurde und
sowas und es wird dann festgestellt,
oh Mist, nehmen wir ein praktisches
Beispiel. Praktisches Beispiel,
was im Vorfeld keiner
wirklich gemerkt hat. Und zwar,
also wirklich
so aus der
Realität jetzt, eins zu eins
so passiert, wo die
alle redundanten Systeme nichts gebracht haben.
Also wir haben eine App
für unsere Außendienst-Mitarbeiter
auf dem Smartphone.
Was die mit der App
machen können, ist eigentlich relativ egal.
Ehrlich gesagt, ich weiß es gar nicht genau, was sie damit
machen können. Aber es gibt eine App
für alle Außendienst-Mitarbeiter.
Der Chuck, danke schon für den Sub.
Und eines Tages
ging die App nicht mehr. Konnte sich nicht
mehr connecten. Warum?
Tja, man wusste
es erst mal nicht. Die haben mich
auch dann morgens angerufen, wir hätten doch
jetzt irgendwas gemacht. Hab ich gesagt, Alter, ich hab doch mit
mit eurer komischen App nichts zu tun.
So,
und ich erspar euch jetzt mal das
ganze Gerate.
Wisst ihr, was es gewesen ist?
Ein Zertifikat.
Und zwar folgender
Zusammenhang.
Wir haben unsere Zertifikate erneuert,
weil Zertifikate
abgelaufen wären in ungefähr
keine Ahnung, 8, 9,
10 Tagen. Was haben wir
gemacht? Wir haben neues Let's Encrypt Zertifikat
geholt und haben das
eingespielt.
Und
daraufhin, mit
bisschen Verzögerung, aber daraufhin, ging dann
halt die App nicht mehr. Und was ist
gewesen? Das Zertifikat
und so, es war alles gültig,
überhaupt gar kein, gar kein
Problem.
Die App
hat
Zertifikat-Pinning
betrieben. Also die haben quasi
geguckt,
dass das Zertifikat von einem
ganz speziellen
Herausgeber sein muss.
Und die haben nicht mitbekommen,
dass wir jetzt, und das schon seit
bestimmt drei Jahren, Let's Encrypt
verwenden.
Ihr Zertifikat lief halt
irgendwie eine ganze Weile
und das war noch von einem anderen Aussteller.
Und
jetzt gab's da halt auch, wie
seit zwei, drei Jahren für alle
Services ein Let's Encrypt Zertifikat
war überhaupt kein Ding, ja. Nur
die App, die hat halt gesagt,
nee, Let's Encrypt
vertraue ich nicht. Ich vertraue nur
diesem einen Aussteller.
Und dann ging die Verbindung
nicht mehr.
Was haben wir gemacht?
Naja, wir haben das alte Zertifikat
wieder eingespielt, das war ja noch gültig für irgendwie
ein paar Tage.
Und die mussten ihre App
updaten.
Und das war auch so ein Meeting,
das hat auch so ein bisschen
untermauert, dass ich da weg
muss. Und zwar,
ich hab gesagt
in diesem Meeting,
dass wir aber, also wir können das
Zertifikat jetzt austauschen.
Sinnvoll, machen wir.
Wir sollten bloß nicht vergessen,
auch mal Planungstechnik, wir sollten bloß
nicht vergessen, dass in sieben oder
acht Tagen das Zertifikat
abläuft. Und wenn dieses Zertifikat
in sieben Tagen noch nicht getauscht ist,
dann kann der
komplette Außendienst nicht mehr arbeiten.
Ich wollte das bloß mal sagen,
dass das allen die Tragweite dieser
Zertifikatssachen bewusst ist.
Und da kam irgendwo ein Management-Typ
an und meinte, ah, das ist doch
jetzt egal, wir haben doch jetzt die Probleme
und nicht in sieben Tagen.
Ich war
wirklich kurz davor,
irgendwie zu erzählen, so nach dem Motto,
dann weint nicht rum das nächste Mal, wenn es kaputt geht.
Ich hab da glaube ich
irgendwas gesagt, so nach dem Motto,
dann sollte man sich im Nachhinein nicht beschweren.
Ich wollte es bloß sagen.
Und es wurde ja
wirklich ganz ganz auf den letzten Drücker
noch getauscht.
Siehste?
Dutti, daran siehst du, selbst wenn
etwas redundant ausgelegt ist,
es gibt immer Fälle,
da kannst du nichts machen.
Wichtig ist,
dass du im Nachhinein dir das
anguckst und dir
vielleicht überlegst, okay, an welcher Stelle
ist uns das dann durch die Lappen gegangen?
Also an welcher Stelle hätten wir es denn
merken können?
Und wenn du halt solche Retrospektiven
eher Richtung
wer ist denn jetzt der Böse machst,
dann verbesserst du halt nichts.
Das ist das,
was bei uns halt ganz gerne dann passiert.
Also sprich,
diese Besprechung wäre dann eher
dazu benutzt zu gucken, wem kann man jetzt
die Schuld in die Schuhe schieben?
Aber weniger
so nach dem Motto, was könnten wir denn machen?
Und diesen Fehler abzufangen im Vorfeld
ist gar nicht mal so einfach.
Also an welcher Stelle soll sowas
festgestellt werden? Das hat ja nichts mit der
App an sich zu tun, die verbuggt ist.
Das hat auch nichts mit irgendwelchen
fachlichen Tests zu tun, die dann fehlschlagen.
Also dieses Problem, das muss
also quasi fast schon einmal auftreten,
dass man nur weiß, dass es existiert,
um sich dann zu überlegen, an welcher
Stelle fackelt man es ab.
Ey, das
dürfen die ja,
aber dann sollen sie sich danach nicht beschweren.
Und das ist das, wo ich auch schon öfters
ähm, tja,
da Diskussionen hatte
und angeeckt bin,
weil genau das eben passiert ist.
Entweder hat man im Vorfeld
gesagt, ja wir nehmen die Probleme
in Kauf, obwohl man darauf hingewiesen wurde
und dann sind die Probleme gekommen, da wollte man nichts mehr wissen.
Oder eben halt sowas, wie ich eben
erzählt hab.
Ja.
Ja Manager, die nicht managen können,
haben wir leider jede Menge.
Es gibt durchaus fähige Manager,
hab ich auch ein paar erlebt.
Aber,
ich hab da irgendwie mittlerweile
schon so ein bisschen ein Gespür,
mal gucken, ob sich das bewahrheitet, ja,
wenn ich jetzt mal die Welt bei einem anderen Arbeitgeber sehe,
ich bin jetzt ja schon lange da.
Ich hab da mittlerweile schon ein gewisses Gespür dafür,
also, wenn manche Leute
oder welche Manager was hinbekommen
und welche nicht, also,
nicht nur von den Leuten, wo ich weiß,
ok, bei denen klappt das meistens,
sondern auch die Herangehensweise
ist irgendwie,
weiß nicht, also,
ich versuch das mal irgendwie zu erklären.
Es gibt Leute,
die versuchen, ok,
das ist eine gute Frage, das kann ich damit,
also, wir müssen das jetzt mal ein bisschen unterscheiden.
Manager Richtung Projektmanagement
oder Richtung Teammanagement und
Führungskraft, das sind ja zwei unterschiedliche Paar Schuhe.
Also, zum Beispiel,
Manager,
die wissen,
dass ihr Plan nicht
eins zu eins so in der Realität
funktionieren wird.
Meistens welche, wo es gut funktioniert.
So blöd das klingt.
Also,
es gibt da so zwei,
könnte man so sagen,
natürlich ist immer
ganz viele Zwischenschritte möglich,
aber es gibt so zwei Herangehensweisen,
die ich gesehen habe.
Leute, die irgendwelche Projekte managen.
Du hast einmal die,
die quasi der Meinung sind,
wenn was negativ ist,
oder wenn was...
Es gibt einmal die Leute,
die der Meinung sind, wenn du auf
Probleme hinweist, das wäre was
Negatives.
Und das siehst du ein bisschen bei Facebook
und Meta aktuell, so nach dem Motto,
die Leute sollen irgendeinen Scheiß entwickeln,
den sie nie im Leben verwenden werden,
wollen, sonst wie, weil es ihr fucking
Job ist, und die Manager erzählen
ihnen dann, wie könnt ihr unser Produkt
nicht lieben, ihr müsst es lieben und benutzen
und nur dann wird es gut,
so nach dem Motto, du glaubst ja nicht an
die Revision und ihr macht das
ja nur schlecht. So Leute gibt es überall.
Also sprich, dass du,
wenn du auf potenzielle
Probleme hinweist, dass
das als was Negatives gesehen wird.
Die gibt es.
Und das sind die, wo es
meistens nicht klappt.
Jetzt projekttechnisch und
Live-Services,
Live-Schalten, bei denen klappt das meistens
nicht. Die erstellen Pläne im
Voraus, die oftmals wenig mit der
Realität zu tun haben, weil, naja,
wenn du nicht auf Probleme hingewiesen
werden darfst, als Manager weißt du das
selbst nicht.
Die erstellen zwar äußerst detailreiche
Pläne und alles, allerdings
enthalten diese Pläne halt,
tja, meistens da nicht die
problematischen Sachen, weil Probleme
darf man ja nicht erzählen. Und
die sind auch sehr von
ihrer, von ihrem
eigenen Management-Skill überzeugt,
so nach dem Motto, wenn ich den Plan
gemacht habe, dann muss der Stuhl befolgt werden,
weil, ähm, das
ist der perfekte Plan, so nach dem Motto.
So, das sind die,
das sind die Sorten Manager, also gerade
Projektmanager, wo ich gesehen habe, da klappt das nicht so richtig.
Bei denen, wo das
klappt, und das sind auch witzigerweise
die, von denen ich zumindest, wo ich weiß,
was die so, ähm, tja,
verdienen, die tatsächlich
anscheinend irgendwie eine Erfolgsprämie
oder so haben, keine Ahnung, weil die verdienen
in der Regel mehr und bei denen klappt das dann auch ganz gut.
Das ist bestimmt, bestimmt ist das
irgendwie ein bisschen an Erfolg gekoppelt,
wäre ja auch blöd. Ganz ehrlich,
woran willst du Projektmanager-Gehälter
beziehungsweise Projektmanagersachen denn koppeln?
Am sinnvollsten natürlich an Projekte
funktionieren, nachdem du sie gemanagt hast.
Zumindest
die Sorte Manager, wo das, wo das
funktioniert,
das sind welche, die sich durchaus anhören,
wenn man, ähm,
Bedenken hat oder Probleme sieht,
die allerdings das nicht überdramatisieren.
Also, du kannst von ausgehen,
wenn neue Sachen eingeführt werden,
Techniker werden dir quasi von morgens bis abends
erzählen, was da dran kacke ist und dass es
schlecht ist und dass es da nicht dran
gedacht wurde und dass dieser Fall nicht getestet wird.
Also im Prinzip erzählen dir quasi Leute den ganzen
Tag, dass irgendwas nicht funktionieren wird.
Aber es ist wichtig, sich das anzuhören
und sich wichtig rauszufiltern als
Manager, okay, was klingt
denn da jetzt irgendwie
kosten-nutzen-relevant?
Also sprich, wir müssen
also sprich,
wenn dir ein Techniker erzählt,
nach drei Jahren Entwicklungszeit
und eine Woche bevor die Anwendung
live geht, die Anwendung ist grundsätzlich
beschissen, die alte war besser und das neue wird
nicht funktionieren, alles crap,
dann könntest du sagen, okay, Mist, wir blasen
alles ab und entwickeln die Anwendung neu.
Das ist ja natürlich unrealistisch, kannste nicht machen.
Ist auch recht
unwahrscheinlich, dass das wirklich so
eintreten wird, so unspezifisch
wie das ist.
Aber wenn dir jemand erzählt,
ja, wir hatten letztens Probleme
mit dem Zertifikat, da und da
und ich glaube in der neuen Anwendung
ist das auch nicht berücksichtigt, denn dann
sollte man sich das vielleicht mal überlegen.
So nach dem Motto, ja, mal
gucken, okay, lass mal noch ein paar Entwickler
einladen, ist das denn wirklich so?
Also die Manager, die sich
Probleme anhören und die irgendwie
einfließen lassen in den Ablauf
und
die gleichermaßen wissen, dass ihr Plan
nie 100% Bestand
haben wird, wenn es denn wirklich dann
losgeht,
das sind eigentlich die, wo es am besten klappt.
Mir hat mal einer von unseren
Managern, von denen ich
den Eindruck habe, dass die Sachen ganz gut
klappen, wenn
er sie macht, der hat mal sinngemäß sowas gesagt
wie, wenn du einen Plan für
alles hast, dann brauchst du auch keinen Manager.
Der ist natürlich
ein bisschen übertrieben, aber
ich gehe mal davon aus, was er meint
ist, und da muss ich
ihm an der Stelle auch recht geben, was ich
bis jetzt gesagt habe, also was er meint
ist, nicht, dass du nicht Sachen
planen solltest, sondern
dass es in der Realität eh
immer ein bisschen anders kommt, ja.
Du hast zwar irgendwelche Ablaufpläne, du
planst eine halbe Stunde dafür ein, du
planst eine Stunde dafür ein, dafür und danach soll
dieser Schritt passieren und sowas,
es passiert immer irgendwas, was nicht
sein sollte, ja. Oder manche
Sachen gehen viel schneller als gedacht,
dafür sind andere Sachen, du hast an der Stelle
wird dann festgestellt, ach Mist, da liegt
ja gar nicht das richtige WLAN am Switch an,
da hat ja noch keiner dran gedacht, Mist, Datenbank
ist erst eine Stunde später verfügbar und sowas
in der Richtung und dann muss ein guter
Manager in der Lage sein und dafür ist er
ein Manager und dafür ist er da
und nur dafür ist er, kriegt er massig Kohle
an der Stelle auch,
dann muss er in der Lage sein, diesen Plan
so anzupassen, dass er weiter
funktioniert, aber diesen einen
Fall berücksichtigt.
Ohne, dass
alles komplett abkackt.
Dafür ist ein guter, der muss das
managen, der muss nicht im Vorfeld
Pläne machen, die 100%
wasserdicht sind, ein Manager muss managen
können und das ist
das, was unglaublicherweise
viele Manager nicht können.
Und ja, das sind so
diese zwei Typen an Managern,
die ich gesehen habe bei uns,
in diese Richtung, wo das geht und ja
dort, wo es klappt
und dort, wo es nicht klappt.
Ach ja, und die größten Dumpschweizer sind meistens auch die
lustigerweise, wo es nicht klappt.
Also derjenige, der mir erzählt hat, so nach dem Motto
Achtung, wir haben jetzt
ein Problem, nicht in sieben Tagen, das ist auch jemand, der
sonst wenig auf die Reihe kriegt.
Wo auch sonst vieles
nicht klappt.
Wohingegen der andere
von diesem Plan, der auch
diesen Spruch gebracht hat, hier mit Manager, wenn alles
klappt, dann brauchst du keinen Manager, bei dem
klappt das besser, die Sachen.
Da gehen auch Sachen in die Hose, aber
im Endeffekt, zum größten Teil, klappt
das ganz gut.
Ja, und was für mich einen guten Manager ausmacht,
du meinst wahrscheinlich, was einen guten Chef ausmacht
in dem Fall, oder? Also was einen guten Manager
ausmacht, habe ich jetzt ja mehr oder weniger erzählt.
Was
viele Leute
sehen ja auch, also Manager
ist Synonym für
Vorgesetzter, Teamleiter.
Würde ich tatsächlich ein bisschen unterscheiden.
Ist es Projektmanagement, ist es irgendwelche andere
oder ist es eben quasi
Teamleitung oder sowas.
Es sind zwar auch Manager, aber es ist ein bisschen
anders gelagert. Also ein Projekt
von irgendeiner Softwareeinführung oder irgendwie
Projektumbau oder sowas, was anderes wie
du bist quasi Teamleiter.
Tja, was ist für mich als guter
Team, was als guter Manager, beziehungsweise
als guter Vorgesetzter, guter Teamleiter wichtig?
Also, ich glaube,
eine ganz entscheidende Sache,
was auch vielen fehlt,
die Fähigkeit dazu,
ist
die
die zwei Welten
oder mehrere Welten
zusammenzubringen.
Und zwar,
wenn
sich Chef, Vorstand,
Abteilung, was auch immer, sich irgendwas
ausdenken,
dann muss das
in relativ ungefilterter
und mit
möglichst hohem
so Wahrheitsgehalt bei denen
ankommen, die es umsetzen sollen.
Und umgedreht,
wenn es irgendwelche
Probleme gibt, da müssen
die auch relativ
realitätsgetreu
weiter oben ankommen,
dass man da richtig drauf reagieren
kann. Und was ich gesehen
habe ist, dort aktuell, wo
ich arbeite,
dass das nicht funktioniert. Also
sprich, mal angenommen,
der oberste Oberchef
denkt sich irgendwie super
neue Sachen aus,
die Vision für 2040
oder keine Ahnung, irgendwas.
Das mag
auch durchaus alles Hand und Fuß haben,
was der sich da ausdenkt, das Problem ist nur,
dass das, was davon
bei einem ankommt, keinen Sinn mehr ergibt,
weil es durch fünf Filterschichten
gelaufen ist, die das irgendwie
umtransformiert haben.
Und umgedreht, wenn du
irgendwelche grundsätzlichen Probleme
siehst in der Firma
und sprichst die an
und es durch
fünf Filterschichten oder durch
zwei, drei Filterschichten, sagen wir mal,
nur auf IT-Ebene,
durch drei, vier Filterschichten
wieder nach oben bringst und jede
Filterschicht lässt davon
das weg, was sie vielleicht
auch nur im entferntesten irgendwie
im schlechten Licht
dastehen lassen könnte,
dann bleibt halt manchmal nicht viel
übrig, weil dein Teamleiter
filtert das weg, was vielleicht negativ
auf sein Team zurückfallen könnte.
Der Gruppenleiter oder
Ressortleiter oder was auch immer es da drüber gibt,
filtert das weg, was für seine
Untergruppen negativ sein könnte,
was ja schon viel mehr sind, dann kommt der Abteilungsleiter,
der filtert nochmal weg, was für seine Abteilung
negativ sein könnte und dann kriegt es der Ober-IT-Typ
und denkt sich, wo ist denn jetzt eigentlich
das Problem, die sollen sich mal nicht so anstellen,
weil eigentlich nichts übrig geblieben ist.
Also das ist eines der wichtigsten
Sachen, die ein Vorgesetzter braucht,
generell in so einer leitenden Position,
die müssen mehrere Welten
zusammenbringen können, man muss wissen, was umgesetzt werden
soll, man muss das verstehen,
was man sich dabei gedacht hat,
das ist ja oftmals der Witz,
man muss verstehen, wie, warum
wollen die das eigentlich machen,
damit man dahinter kommt,
was überhaupt
die Richtung ist,
in die das gehen soll.
Es ist ja oftmals nicht so damit getan, dass
jemand zu dir sagt, hey,
es ist nicht so, dass der IT-Chef jetzt
sagt, installieren wir mal drei Web-Server.
Das wird der nicht sagen.
Der wird sagen, unsere Vision für
2023 ist blablabla
XY-Service für
sowieso anzubieten.
Dass es darauf resultiert, dein Team muss drei
Web-Server installieren, da hat er keine Ahnung von.
Muss er ja auch nicht.
Aber du musst trotzdem wissen,
was ist denn
der größere Zusammenhang dahinter?
Also wofür sind denn diese drei
Web-Server? Vielleicht
machst du ja dann beim Aufsetzen
Sachen anders, weil du weißt,
das muss sich ja in dieses Gesamtbild einfügen.
Das muss man schon verstehen.
Das müssen Vorgesetze
können, das kriegen viele nicht auf die Reihe.
In beide Richtungen
ist das wichtig,
das weiter zu kommunizieren.
Was auch wichtig ist,
dass es Vorgaben gibt,
auf die man
sich verlassen kann.
Wenn heute einer sagt,
wir haben ein Ticketsystem
und unsere Vorstellung
ist, dass Tickets quasi auf diese
Art und Weise bearbeitet werden.
Dann ist es wichtig, dass man sich da
insofern drauf verlassen kann, dass nicht
zwei Wochen später einer sagt, hey,
warum hast du dieses Häkchen im Ticket nicht gemacht?
Das weiß man doch mittlerweile, dass das
gemacht werden soll. Und du denkst dir, hä?
Habt ihr nicht vor zwei Wochen noch was anderes
erzählt? So nach dem Motto,
dieses Feature ist nur eingebaut
für die Abteilung, wir sollen es gar nicht verwenden.
Hä? Was denn jetzt?
Das ist wichtig, dass die Sachen
klar sind, wie was gemacht
wird und wenn man es so macht,
wie das kommuniziert
wurde, dass danach keiner sagen kann,
du hast es verkehrt gemacht und hättest es besser wissen müssen.
Weil es ist nicht dein Job, das zu wissen.
Es ist der Job deines Chefs, dir das zu sagen.
Oder zumindest die Stelle,
die sich das ausgedacht hat, soweit bekannt zu machen,
dass es jeder wissen kann.
Genauso wenig, wie es der Job deines Chefs ist,
den Chef selber zu installieren.
Das kriegen auch einige nicht hin.
Also es muss gewisse...
Das ist auch was, was mich immer ein bisschen aufregt,
wenn man
im Vorfeld sagt,
wir müssen
jetzt in drei Monaten XYZ
umgezogen haben,
wir wissen, dass es dabei zu Problemen
kommen wird, aber das ist
so wichtig, wir nehmen die Probleme
in Kauf,
und wenn die auftreten,
der Zeitplan ist uns halt so wichtig,
und wenn es Probleme gibt, dann treten die halt auf.
So, und dann treten die Probleme auf,
und dann sagen die Leute dann, was?
Ihr hättet ja noch mal
gesagt, dass es zu Problemen kommen kann.
Die Probleme nehmen wir natürlich
nicht in Kauf, so.
Das regt mich dann immer auf,
weil ihr Dummschwätze, Alter.
Das Einzige, was an diesen Positionen
ist, was die sich dann denken, ist, oh fuck,
das könnte jetzt ja negativ auf mich zurückfallen.
Vorher sind das ungelegte
Eier. Vorher sind das ungelegte
Eier, weil, das sind abstrakte Probleme,
oh, da sagt irgendeiner, das könnte Probleme
geben, ach was, es gibt ja noch gar kein Problem, solange
es kein Problem gibt,
tja, ist mir das egal. Und dann gibt's
eins, dann sagt man, nee, das geht jetzt natürlich
nicht.
Das sind halt so Leute,
die versuchen sich immer so durchzumogeln.
Deswegen ist es
wichtig, wenn man
in solchen Unternehmen arbeitet, wo es öfters
vorkommt,
manchmal Protokolle
sich durchlesen von irgendwelchen übergreifenden
Runden, das mache ich teilweise ganz gerne.
Und wenn es so
Entscheidungen gibt, man bekommt dann mit der Zeit
so ein gewisses Gespür dafür, welche
Aussagen, die jetzt getroffen wurden,
höchstwahrscheinlich nochmal relevant
sind, sich aufschreiben, wann was
gesagt wurde. Weil dann können sie sich
nicht mehr rausdrehen. Es ist schlimm, es ist doof, dass
sowas notwendig ist, ja. Aber die
das ist auch was, was ich
an Führungskräften mies finde, ist,
wenn Führungskräfte unter selektivem
Gedächtnisverlust leiden.
So nach dem Motto, das habe ich nie gesagt!
Oder das wurde so nie kommuniziert!
Das ist deswegen immer gut,
wenn man dann sagen kann, doch,
auf der Teamrunde
vor zwei Wochen, wurde genau
das gesagt. Da können
sich dann immer schlecht wieder rausdrehen, weil du hast ja dann
mehr Leute, die sich auch dran erinnern.
Und vielleicht findest du sogar noch das Protokoll,
wo irgendwie ansatzweise was dazu drinnen steht.
Also selektiver Gedächtnisverlust
bei Führungskräften ist auch immer so ein Ding.
So, genug dazu.
Ey, Alter, das klingt wie eine Frage von der Personalabteilung in einem Vorstellungsgespräch.
Wenn du einem
angehenden Manager einen Tipp geben könntest,
welcher wäre das? Das klingt einzeln wie
eine Frage aus einem Vorstellungsgespräch.
Das könnte ich mir vorstellen,
das könnte man genau 1 zu 1 dort
fragen.
Ja, ich hab da jetzt schon genug
zu gesagt, keine Ahnung.
War bestimmt die ein oder andere
Sachen dabei.
Also ich finde,
man muss es nicht übertreiben.
Man muss nicht wirklich für
jede Besprechung ein Protokoll machen. Das ist wirklich
Overkill. Gerade wenn du sagst,
hey, lass uns mal hier irgendwie XY
schnell zusammen angucken mit drei Leuten. Da brauchst du kein
Protokoll dafür. Aber wenn das so Sachen sind,
wo so relevante
Infos geshared werden, da ist es tatsächlich nicht
verkehrt.
Natürlich, das ist wieder
ein typischer Fall von meinem aktuellen
Arbeitgeber, wo
Vorstellung und Wirklichkeit weiter
auseinander liegen.
Warum ich nicht ins Management gehe?
Weil ich mir den Scheiß nicht geben will.
Das ist wirklich der letzte Job, den ich machen
will. Das ist ja auch nicht einfach.
Es ist wirklich nicht einfach,
das ordentlich zu machen.
Gerade
unteres Management ist stressig.
Unteres Management ist, du kriegst
Teamleiter zum Beispiel. Du kriegst permanent
Einlauf
von deinen Chefs und du kriegst permanent
Gemeckere und Anschiss von deinen Leuten.
In alle Richtungen. Du wirst eigentlich von allen
Seiten nur angekackt. Als Teamleiter.
Als Teamleiter ist
eigentlich echt undankbare Position.
Jedenfalls kann
man wahrscheinlich noch sagen.
So.
Das habe ich vergessen, weil ich vorher noch
sagen wollte. Egal.
Ja.
Ich wollte was zu Protokoll.
Ach ja. Da gibt es bei meinem aktuellen
Arbeitgeber auch so ein
Trend.
Und zwar
seinerweile
seit Jahren schon
hat sich etabliert, dass man
für Teamrunden und solche Sachen
Protokolle anfertigt.
Ist ja auch sinnvoll.
Und
irgendwann hat sich dann einer überlegt,
die Protokolle
sollten doch öffentlich für alle
einsehbar sein.
Also für alle. Nicht öffentlich im Internet,
sondern öffentlich für alle, die in der Firma arbeiten.
Einsehbar sein. Da könnte man so ein bisschen gucken
und dann nicht so Geheimniskrämerei.
So.
Das ist natürlich eine doofe Idee gewesen.
Aus mehreren Gründen.
Auf der einen Seite ist es cool. Man kann sehen,
was andere so treiben und mal nachgucken vielleicht.
Haben die schon angefangen mit
meiner Sache, die ich da beauftragt habe.
Das ist übrigens
ein Thema, da würde ich
gerne ein Video zu sehen
von
Wie heißt das Spiel?
Der Frankfurter Professor
auf YouTube.
So ein Spieltheorie-Video
zu sehen.
Riek.
Da würde ich gerne ein Video von sehen, weil
der macht ja immer Videos zu
das eine sagen, aber falsche Anreize
setzen, dass es die Leute nicht machen.
Und zwar bei uns ist es so, es gibt Protokolle
und die sind jetzt öffentlich.
Da wurde sich entschieden,
Protokolle von Teamrunden öffentlich zu machen.
Und
ich habe halt gemerkt, dass das
Anreize dafür setzt,
dass die Leute
eben nicht mehr wichtige und brisante
Sachen und
wichtige Informationen in die
Protokolle schreiben. Beispielsweise, ich habe das
erlebt bei mir im Team.
Da gibt es halt so ein paar Themen, die
ziehen sich schon relativ lange hin, sind auch relativ
unbeliebt und jedes Mal,
wenn jemand ein Protokoll schreibt und
einer was dazu sagt und dann fragt,
soll das auch ins Protokoll?
Sagt mein Chef, ne ne,
lass das mal aus dem Protokoll raus. Warum?
Weil wenn irgendjemand dieses Protokoll liest,
dann stellt er fest,
ah,
hm, blödes Thema,
was machen die denn da? Und dann
kommt er zu meinem Chef und fragt nach
und es geht meinem Chef auf den Keks.
Deswegen kommt das da nicht ins Protokoll.
Ah ne ne ne, das müssen wir so nicht ins Protokoll
schreiben. Was
wieder kompletten Sinn dahinter, diese
Protokolle zu erstellen, weil das ja oftmals auch
wichtige Informationen sind, die da irgendwie so ein bisschen
absurd
werden lässt.
Das
für mich einfach, also
von der Idee her gut,
aber praktisch hat es
genau das Gegenteil bewirkt.
Ich muss immer noch genug arbeiten, glaub's mir.
Ich arbeite zwar nur vier Tage
und das schon seit 2011
oder 2012 oder 2011 oder irgendwie
weile, weile vier Tage Woche.
Das ist auch das Beste, was ich jedem empfehlen kann, vier Tage Woche
zu arbeiten.
Aber ich arbeite nach wie vor
immer nur vier Tage Woche.
Ich arbeite immer nur vier Tage Woche.
Ich arbeite immer nur
vier Tage Woche.
Aber ich arbeite nach wie vor
80%. Also kaum
arbeiten ist für mich was anderes als 80%,
also vier Tage arbeiten.
Also 80% heißt ja im Endeffekt
vier Tage arbeiten, drei Tage
frei.
Genau, das kommt ja auch
noch dabei. Nicht nur Sachen weglassen,
sondern dass auch sehr viel Selbstbeweihräucherung
ins Protokoll kommt, was eigentlich
jeder in dem Team weiß und was überhaupt
für einen großen Informationsgehalt er hat.
Na gut.
Ich baue jetzt gerade eine Firma auf.
Und dann dachte ich, good luck, have fun,
2023 geht jetzt los.
Easy.
Ich habe jetzt leider kein
Raketen-Emoji.
Aber, nee,
noch nicht mal ansatzweise
sowas in der Richtung.
Aber der Start ist immer holprig.
Tja, Leute.
Ich habe Hunger as fuck. Ich bin schon
drei Stunden on.
Ich habe viel zu viel geschwätzt
wieder. Wir haben kaum was geguckt.
Wir haben zwei Videos geguckt, Leute.
Musst euch mal vorstellen. Wir haben zwei Videos
geguckt und ich habe drei Stunden
geschwätzt. Wie habe ich denn das auf die Reihe gekriegt
wieder?
Du musst 2023 immer noch
durchs Bahnhofviertel. Ja, das ist
das Problem.
Du musst 2023 immer noch
durchs Bahnhofviertel. Ja, muss ich, muss ich.
Mein neuer Arbeitgeber ist so
ungefähr 800 oder sagen wir mal 1000, 1000
Meter, so im Umkreis von 1000 Metern
von meinem aktuellen weg.
Zockst du generell noch irgendwelche Games?
Oh ja. Oldschool
MMOs.
Viel zu viel.
Ich habe glaube ich, ich habe letztens
mal geguckt, ich habe so
viele, also der Server ging
online am
12.
20.
Irgendwie hier so ging der Server
online und ich habe im
Durchschnitt glaube ich sieben Stunden am Tag oder so
gespielt.
Oh, viel zu leise. Warum ist
das so leise?
Soll
nicht so leise sein, soll lauter sein.
Testen, testen,
ob es jetzt besser ist.
Ach, scheiß drauf.
Volle Pulle.
Fliff.
Wer spielt
freiwillig Fliff?
Es kommt als nächstes
Medien 2 oder sowas.
Ne.
So Crap
wird nicht gespielt hier.
Leute, ich gehe jetzt was essen.
Ich habe Hunger.
PPoFatTime.
So sieht es aus. Du hast predicted.
Ich gehe jetzt was essen. Ich habe Hunger.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Und dann machen wir wieder ein bisschen
High IQ Technik Stells.
Bis dahin machts gut.
C.U.